you what is up people of the world
thank you thank you yes thank you please
clap
please clap uh today's episode is
sponsored by hellofresh and it is Friday
baby July 29th
today we are joined by the very funny
friend of the show Whitney Cummings
hello and thank you for being here would
never have done this had I known it was
live yeah I know well here we are so
don't mess up it's a bad idea no take
back okay it's a bad idea you've been
live you do live yes you're calling the
Howard Stern and stuff yeah sometimes I
would have like I don't know slept more
or a lot more responses
but why so so when you bring up
Chappelle Bobby Lee I'm just I'm ready
oh yeah I have a lot okay okay but I do
uh want your fans to tell me if I'm
super off and recommending Dumont is a
part of y'all's yeah we were just
talking about this website dumwa I don't
think it's a website Instagram account
they have a podcast now too and it's
basically like really great
and people will like email about you
know famous people that they work for
they'll be like I'm an assistant to this
person and they send flowers to this
person and the this person's credit card
gets declined like it's just the most
below so let me try to find a it's me
like I I can't wait to go and follow it
but also kind of makes me anxious too me
too but wait you know what you're the
kind of person that does the right thing
when no one's watching you're fine
that's me all the time I never get
credit I'm always doing the best thing
when people are not watching people are
watching people are watching I'm such an
[ __ ]
that is actually true about Ethan do you
think I feel like that sounds like
ironic sorry sorry it is it really is
true oh my God thank you I love you he
makes an ass of himself when everybody's
watching
nice it does nice things
form of Dyslexia that you would have
been very lucrative yeah it well I am
actually dyslexic
lucrative so thank you by the way I'm on
their Instagram page and all I see is
like [ __ ] post memes oh where's the
gossip okay hold on go to theirs stories
yeah maybe go to their saved stories
okay yeah but if you go on like I think
Sunday is the big day that they really
come in with the like I'm sitting next
to Ryan Gosling and he's uncircumcised
like it's so he left this much tip but
here's here's that's the reason I kind
of got into it was
um I posted one day like if if a
celebrity doesn't return their car or if
people don't return their cards like
they're monsters or something and I was
like if anyone sees any celebrities not
returning your card at the grocery store
oh oh the car yeah like take a picture
like I just like was like just being
announced okay wow did you get busted
for doing that no I I always return I
always return the card it's a really big
part of who I am yeah you have to if if
to me if I'm like dating a new person
yeah well within the first couple days
we have to go to the grocery store and I
have to see if they I've even fixed
other people's where they leave it like
you know it's gonna hit a car love it
I've gone and fixed that
so thank you when nobody was watching
when nobody was watching American Heroes
hey by the way this could be a good time
to show Whitney about partner
I know Carter oh you do know your friend
to the show he called in so yes he's a
hero who used to be on radio show yeah
he is part of a radio Kevin and Bean oh
was he I don't know he's so yeah radio
was this thing that you replaced that
guy you took his shirt you took his job
all of his fans so now he had to start
an Instagram about it he lives in a
parking lot are you serious by the way
I'm trying to so here I'm just trying to
find one juicy Dubois okay it says
subject new Addison Ray Apatow film
titled girls night Addison is the fun
one and Iris is the bookish one hasn't
been filmed yet well that's just like
this gossip that's like a little okay
July 2022. there was one about me that
was like sitting across from Whitney
Cummings at an airport in Austin and she
just scraped the cheese and pepperoni
off of three Pizza Hut pizzas and ate it
all at once with her hands
it was a hundred percent true and and
why yeah you do that because I'm a
Epicurean wizard I'm a culinary genius
and I'm a classic [ __ ] wait I want to
back it up here so you're at the airport
you ordered three small cheese pizzas
well like just the cheese pizza like a
Pizza Hut personal pan pizza are you
doing keto is that why I just really
wanted a big hot glob of cheese that's
what the [ __ ] is up I totally understand
that sometimes
I totally get it hashtag girl boss
yeah I uh I sometimes it's too much
cheese for me so I take it off and then
he's like what is wrong with you and he
takes it and it is that's called soul
mates yeah together
together or make a normal person
together you make one normal person
um so so you actually do that though
that's really interesting to know so
you'll buy three personal pizzas take
them and sit and then hey hey Gabe hold
on one sec buddy and you'll sit and
you'll scrape the cheese off and then
you'll eat that yes
[ __ ] there was actually more to that
uh if we actually want to find it let's
find it
I'm like I did like I did sandwich it
into like
something like a taco and you didn't
think anyone was watching I didn't think
I have it do you want me to read it you
found it yeah [ __ ] I also have Whitney
Cummings on my flight from Denver to LGA
what's LG LaGuardia oh she sat across
from me in the terminal and ate the
wildest thing
she had three Pizza Hut cheese pizzas
and multiple grab-and-go sandwiches
she took the deli meat out of the
sandwich and scraped the cheese from the
pizza and ate it like a taco threw the
rest out at 7am I would never believe
that was true like it's too crazy I
would be like that's the most ridiculous
[ __ ] and that's when I was like oh this
side is legit because I can corroborate
like that is so but also it's too crazy
a thing to make up so you have to
believe that it's true that's the
craziest [ __ ] I would have immediately
thought this is like a meme like where
people just make up the craziest story
they can think of yeah and she will also
check with you sometimes she'll DM me
and be like is this true
what's happening here oh this is oh so
this is okay hey Gabe what's up baby
by the way I I was listening to your
podcast doing that and my dog started
howling
what's up dude what you doing what you
up to today
I'm at the costumes they're doing some
early
very early
yeah it's not even you're not even alone
they won't have Halloween stuff will
they yeah do they have Halloween well
it's July yeah thanks so what are you
looking to buy out there
maybe another mask
okay okay let's take you want to listen
why don't you take off the one you're
wearing sorry oh Whitney
he is Rose jokes no we don't roast games
he is what he's just an Untouchable girl
yeah I agree only the utmost reverence
forget it yeah that being said Winnie
you're great on The Comedy Central roast
thank you
there's a time and place we love it's a
time and place
what I did for the
that would be my move for the video what
does the cow say let's do this
no no you say move you do moo moo
moo
can I get it [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] baby
[Music]
Moon
I'm not allowed to make jokes you can
you can you can I just saying like I
mean if if you were
let me just ask let me ask you a
theoretical question if we were talking
to like um
the Holy One what's the Dalai Lama his
Holiness would you be making gags
yes I would
um
hell yeah [ __ ] baby [ __ ] oh that feels a
little um like pink yeah that's a little
the elephant one feels like a little too
um Eyes Wide Shut yeah well you put that
one Scientology vibes
that has elephant ears and it looks his
dick looks like an elephant trunk
I guess I haven't I guess I know way
more why do you know so much yeah what's
going on yes I'm just so much younger
than you guys you don't get it yeah okay
a squid game math that's what I was
trying to think of
yeah it's like the eagle
yeah so
um they're all so creepy yeah there's
just a lot of options there buddy yeah
What's this called right here
which one were you recommending I can't
go wrong with the gorilla oh gorilla
[ __ ] baby zebra zebra zebra oh [ __ ] my
dick [ __ ]
and how about this horse [ __ ] in my ass
[ __ ] horse [ __ ] baby
[ __ ] baby
oh where's is there a horse there yeah
who made that sound I go for the
dalmatian [ __ ] baby horse [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah the cat's actually kind of
surprising and fresh the cat okay that's
cute yeah it does it just it doesn't
look spooky the other ones feel a little
macabre
I think we need the horse because it's
like [ __ ] horse [ __ ] [ __ ]
in my ass [ __ ]
what about a Spider-Man outfit
Spider-Man outfit those are always good
those are good actually I like those
answers those are cool yeah is that for
adults or oh that's a big ass mask
Spiderman oh all right well you know
what happy Halloween shopping I'm glad
you're you're gonna be prepared Nobody's
Gonna Catch You unready for Halloween
tits
you're in the baby section maybe get out
of there
I don't wanna get in trouble yeah
can you oh Panda I like the panda can
you do um a wolf call for me
we cut out there
yeah oh wait was that a meme
well Gabe listen love you so much buddy
you do some good shopping out there this
is Whitney Cummings by the way I didn't
introduce you hi yeah Whitney Whitney
come oh my God this I mean he fired back
I can't believe he went there I feel
like we're even you know what I deserve
that
Fair
Whitney come
on any day now I can't wait to happen
all right Gabe you take care all right
you keep pressuring love you buddy
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah baby oh
that's what I call Gabe he calls in
every Friday yeah I know I listened I
listened to the last episode
um in the last couple because I want to
be all caught up okay
I did also bring something for Zach so
why did Zach get why is that getting a
present because it's not a present it's
I can't hear about the ingrowns anymore
oh my god wow who I don't know who this
stuff who's that right here back in the
corner there okay so I brought
everything you need to get rid of your
Ingress holy [ __ ] thank you so much wait
I I'm so curious to do it because I get
them a lot sort of I get them like
really bad about OCD I went on Prozac oh
here I'll you can take that those are
like cuticle softeners and stuff I went
on Prozac to stop doing like obsessively
digging into oh my God oh my God my
ingrown toenails so deep and the more
you do it the worse it gets because it
gets deeper deeper but I would do it so
obsessively like my feet would bleed oh
my God it was like it was like it's
painful really that's what Zach said I
know the struggle but this is something
called baby foot I'm going to show you
something really gross if you don't want
to put on camera no yeah we will put it
on camera and and by the way and you're
going to show your photo I mean people
well do you want falling over themselves
to see that okay so what well look this
this show and I I'm at five let's get me
down to four today
um you are I have a perfect score on
what okay well let's see them and then
I'll be the judge of that oh my God
Whitney what what is going on here what
so this is something called baby foot
where you put this on are you guys
seeing this can you say what we're
saying today's the day that I just
completely
um get off PornHub entirely well there's
probably all I had to do there's
probably people that are interested very
good points is single now wait before
you pull up so
um there are definitely pictures on here
oh my God Whitney there's photos on what
on your web
there's photos on there you can't show
well I think they're from your Instagram
like
you have perfect five stars beautiful
feet fix it well let's see here though
but to be honest you said you have a
perfect five star uh-huh now don't show
the screen first is that a lie well I
just wanna I just want to be totally
fair okay to Wiki fee because I take
this website seriously you can show it
now as you you'll notice there's a small
sliver missing out of the the uh
just saying more like nine yeah
I actually didn't realize this was such
a legitimate website that I figured it'd
be like four or five there's no in
between like so that's a program oh yeah
dude no yeah oh yeah they're not
rounding up yeah we got banned on
wikiFeet why no we were gaming the
system
air now what are we on Alexis YouTube
live streaming we're on gab or whatever
or no we're we we air after the left
can't meme on uh uh on parlor yeah yeah
true parlor right um no we were gaming
the system I was number one on the
website amazing like by far right right
and they and then it turned into the and
then we were tanking our enemies scores
to one and boosting people we liked and
they that Webster got so mad at us after
a while they turned off rating for all
men we destroyed the whole men's side
and they removed the leadership and
people tried to make him a sort of a
fake profile but like to still have him
on there and they removed it was called
like Ethel clean or some [ __ ] huh I mean
what is their business model no clue I
think it's the Love of the Game it's
just love of the game what are they why
do they care then like are they good
they love it it does look like it has
the same web designer as eBay well let
me show no yeah this look like it like
if I like this looks like a eight chance
this looks like you'd be buying like
fentanyl cocaine often yeah like the
Silk Road Darkness Go Daddy like what I
think for people who are into fit maybe
this is exactly what you described
they're aesthetic this is literally
Orthopedic it is a very Orthopedic
website the food pictures are they're
fentanyl it is like if aerosols made a
website now let me show you basically
because this is the men's side and they
take it super seriously oh wow and uh if
you still go by top rating here
oh did it they deliver did they disable
it yeah oh my God that's such a shame
The Guild has broken we broke the
website we literally broke Wiki feet I
mean it doesn't seem like it was on
sorry solid footing it was
um well anyway let's get back to
Whitney's feet score yes very seriously
tell us about this
um by the way I hate it one of my
biggest pet peeves is when um people
specify that something's not an ad
you know and people like you guys this
is not an ad I just love that this is
not an ad and you're like no like no you
don't get those like no one thought it
was no one cares right and then they're
like it's not an ad guys that it's
always something that's like like but
like Vicks Vapor Rub is amazing
bro didn't need you so is this an ad or
no okay no this is an ad
um I need to look into camera and hold
it if you could um no this is just like
some crazy brand so this is this has
saved your life what does it do
basically you put your foot in it I mean
I think everyone should do it yeah look
better in general you put it on for like
an hour and then over the course of like
two weeks all the dead skins off are you
getting a good shot of her foot and it
it softens your ingrows so much that you
can really easily well you could really
use it
because his gets uh so dry and you know
what it's actually not that bad right
now but like the stuff
I actually I recommended that yeah
that is
um perfect for you your feet look like
legumes but I I know that we're sort of
uh neck and neck kick yeah
I've got like like really fun to peel it
off but your heel looks so fun it looks
I'm very like OCD I love pop music I
love watching zip popping videos I love
peeling
comfortable that looks fun to me I can't
do pop and you can't do watch zip
popping videos do you pop Ethan's it's
never no she doesn't do that ingrowns no
no I don't have ingrowns
I have a perfect body perfect well-oiled
machine
you never have ingrown hairs
no he also has no back pain and perfect
teeth
explain all that you see your teeth well
they don't look good I'm just saying
I've never had cavities no cavities
that's genetic though I don't have any
mouth problems do you have mouth
problems the words that come out of it
yes
do you have a what's your dental
situation like uh it's pretty good I
think I recently had to get a couple
like fillings taken out but for me to
get go under I have to have
six novocaine shots last time six like
they cannot get my face numb like I have
a really hard time getting dental work I
don't know so I just metabolize it
really quickly like when you get a
cavity filled how many ice I have over
the years I became more worse and worse
with handling those things so last time
I had to do stuff they they did all the
shots like you're describing a lot and
they gave me Xanax too or something they
gave me some pills that started to get
me like drowsy it's like a full episode
I get like panicky crying like before
anything happens to me it's just it's
become worse over there but you she had
a really kind of unusual procedure where
they had to graft gums because their gum
lines were receding mine are too though
it was kind of gnarly is that from the
brushing did they tell you to stop using
a hard to I had to switch to a like
toothbrush look how high mine is worse
yeah you look okay that looks pretty
okay your teeth look beautiful these are
seating so the one thing that really
helped me they made me switch to
electric toothbrush and with that one
even if you want to you end up not
brushing hard for some reason yes it's
it's it really helps particularly yeah
so that really helped me but I did there
was one here specifically that I'm not
even sure what exactly happened here but
I had to it went down really you could
see like a root almost yeah it was
really bad so they had to graft gum from
the top of my mouth and then put it here
but it worked great and it just grows
back yeah whoa dude it was dude we're
[ __ ] aliens man that's wild
I feel like I'm gonna have to do that I
had to get these like this like fluoride
topical thing going I don't know this
makes you feel old let's talk about
something
like this and I don't see any cavities
when you show them no I have a ton in
the back oh you do I had my deal with
cavities was because I had so many like
eating disorders and stuff and for a
while I went through just eating like
dried fruit like when you're young pure
sugar probably not yeah it's just candy
so I had a lot of cavities in between my
teeth because I wasn't flossing until
you know so the in-between they have to
like dig out wow yeah it's just like a
nightmare and then removing the old ones
they say the Mercury will leak into your
system oh might you remove the Old
Mercury fillings oh my God how old are
you you put mercury in your mouth I'm
sure the temple
um
radiation
uranium okay look when I was in the
Triangle sureways Factory the Dental
Care Program someone went to college
um but you know you know what I've
gotten into these videos and I I don't
know there's not a lot of people
watching but I love them there's the
dentist to get little cameras in there
mouth and you can watch them like
shaving teeth apart no and like shaving
out the rot and it's so [ __ ]
interesting I mean it's very
uncomfortable to watch but it's
incredible and I've never seen what
actually goes on there it's very cool I
hate that in fact you want to pull one
of those up guys I'm kind of not sure
what you mean like they'll get the
cavity out they'll just scoot out they
basically you just see it watching them
do the dental work like a perfect shot
and yeah they have like a little sanding
tool and you can like see the rot and
they like let's just spit out scoop it
out what fascinates me is that like you
and I have vampire teeth oh yeah we have
these sharp ones she doesn't at all I
always wish I didn't have I'm just
fascinated by some of us have such sharp
canines in some it's a genetic I know
what's your ancestry entirely 100
Ashkenazi Jew
100 like
99.7 or something like that and then
point three percent his is like a like
half a page and mine is like three pages
of different stuff yeah yeah because it
is weird when you look at people's teeth
and you're just like that is crazy we
have canines and you don't is where you
came from you had to rip meat apart less
and we did I think the canine thing is
just like a one specific like Gene like
the widow's peak you know or like a cow
left it's just like a little one of
those things yeah because I was reading
about how um uh based on how inset your
eyes are can say a lot about how much
your ancestors were punched in the face
and how violent they were yeah so the
deeper you're on yes exactly our
ancestors we've been through some [ __ ]
yeah
yours are very really they're not I
thought not dupe really I feel like mine
are big but not deep yeah you know so if
I got punched in the face
it wouldn't really dude you're blowing
my mind can you punch yourself in the
face yes it's fascinating to me like how
they do like if right now we wanted to
have let's say uh you and I are gonna
have an affair and you're gonna cheat on
Ela with me
and how will we do it WhatsApp yeah
what's up what's up is very secure
actually why I feel like that only
married guys text me on there really
yeah can you just text me directly why
am I going to this European Euro app
well I love it that's so funny internet
cafe we use WhatsApp because there's
like our house there's not great
connection there right right so why
what's up works way better I love that
in the most fancy neighborhoods it's
just like how are you not suing yeah
your neighborhood right I was in I think
you're not your neighborhood but like
close by of going to a kind of rich
person's house and the big cause in
everyone's lawn there were all these
signs that said do not let the Bulgari
Hotel come in like a Bulgari Hotel
coming in to like like Beverly Hills
like up in the hills and it's just like
I've seen those signs you've seen the
signs it's a five-star hotel Bulgari is
the jewelry brand yeah they're like do
not let a Bulgari Hotel and Spa come in
here our neighborhood is not other
people's Retreat it's like what why
can't you let other people work they're
like no minimum wage jobs in our
neighborhood yeah that's pretty wild
it's like let you know let your parents
that you're flying in from Pensacola
stay there
well they're just Rich elitist [ __ ]
I mean like that's their big cause in
this day and age that's what they're
putting signs in their lawns for that's
when I was like the wildfires
this is the place for them to start yeah
we're gonna yeah is that a threat uh
that was a threat that was actually an
active threat okay so how are we gonna
secretly have an affair so if WhatsApp I
think let me think I'm just curious yeah
I mean WhatsApp is good because
it's encrypted but but who are you
hiding it from because WhatsApp the
government can't spy on you necessarily
but you can get subpoenaed so if you're
talking about crimes that's a good place
if you're talking about infidelity I
mean that's going to show up on your
phone and she's probably gonna open my
phone and see it there so if you're uh
we'll probably just want a second phone
I mean sorry I'm just trying to say
untraceable activity what's up let's
yeah you're getting too interesting to
it in this reality
you started you started LARPing no you
had me to go there I just mean like what
is the way that won't be the the data
won't be saved anywhere I would say I
would say it's probably like underground
software what are you up to wait no I'm
just curious
dude this is what um no like what's the
other one that everyone's using now Dan
you probably know of one what's the one
there's probably like deep level
criminal apps like no it's just that all
my friends think they're so freaking
important you have to be like I changed
my signal oh okay yeah here's my new
number really I think it's just like our
friends like our numbers get put on
Reddit all the time like I don't even
care anymore yeah I just get like I
spent a day getting dick pics by the way
this show by the way this show yeah I
talked about on this show
you get to see people's bathrooms in
their living rooms I love that [ __ ] so
tell me about your experience because
yeah the last thing on the show you
basically put out a call for our male
fans to send you their cop your their
[ __ ] and by the way I also want to say
like I've been touring I just did like
70 cities before I shot the special
y'all's fans are
so lovely thank you they are so lovely
good job you guys believable they show
up in the teddy I try to send you photos
I do yeah yeah you do they're always the
ones that like when I'm like signing
stuff at the end they like patiently
wait and they like come up at the end
they are the best so it's shocking yeah
um but uh you know definitely not
murdered yeah that's the point
you know so many cities that's why I
shot my um special in Newark I was like
so many comedians now are getting so
famous and so much publicity off of
getting assaulted on stage so I shot my
special work to make sure I got
assaulted on stage yeah sure still
nothing
um but yeah so that was uh no your fans
are like Delight even when they send
dick pics they're like I hope this is
okay
we love respect booking I mean a
respectful dick pic is everything I
think so too but it must be what I
realized is like oh that must be
vulnerable to like send a dick pic and
not hearing his back so I got so many
and I was like oh God I don't want them
to think did you put in the work to
respond I did as many as I could yeah
yeah you know but it's some but seeing
just you can tell if it hasn't been read
if it says red that's when I realized it
was unfair when it just said red
underneath it it's like a photo of my
boobs once to a guy and didn't respond
for like two hours and I sent it to all
my friends to be like oh my dad's weird
it was weird and then he was like hey
sorry I just got this I was in church oh
my God the weird Beverly Hills Church
you know the one that's like it's kind
of Scientology there's like it's called
The Log cab um the guy got me too I
think so hold on he saw your boobs and
then what was his response well he was
like just got that I set my boobs to all
my friends I ruined half my friendships
I was like is this weird like is this
girl like what happened and uh like
because you know nipple hair is
sometimes weird oh you show up in photos
that you don't see otherwise and they're
like long like
um and uh so I you only notice your
nipple hair when you're having sex like
during the day like once a year you're
like that's I gotta be honest man I
didn't really know about women having
nipple hair and that but they do yeah
and I in college I think it was the
first woman I slept with and uh I have
to make an eye contact with her I'm just
saying that like hey it's not her I want
my I know I want to say specifically
it's not Ila the nipple hair girl I'm
not the nippler girl but I know but she
had like some long ass [ __ ] nipple
here yeah just and like I was like okay
you know no judgment but he just shot
she kind of surprised me took me and
good surprises us too notice it's a
it surprises us too and when does the
nipple hair thing start happening
I definitely noticed it more like in my
20s but I think I don't know if it's
because I started plucking it it started
growing longer I said that's gonna be
painful plug not anymore my boots have
been I have no nerve endings yeah yeah
they've seen words
yeah
I hate I've been
having any store for 15 years
they just get along so fast you'll pluck
them everything like four days later
you'll have one long one and like a
couple like oily ones and you're just
like what is the biological basis for
this yeah because I wonder what a
natural nip like how hairy does it get
and I wonder does it get more or less
hairy when you have kids
you can answer that and does not get
worse like no I haven't had a worse case
because I'm curious if the nipple hair
is supposed to be for the baby when it's
breastfeeding like what's the purpose no
hair in their mouth I wouldn't know by
the way because I didn't breastfeed huh
but no um those uh it didn't get worse
yeah so interesting I did have that fear
though I was like what's going to happen
to me when I'm pregnant like my body is
going to get all worse I don't know if I
can breastfeed if you have fake boobs
yeah you think you can but
um the kid's gonna I don't know how to
get an eye patch I mean I don't think
because like I have a helmet for the
rest of his life I don't think so if you
just have like a thing on there right
but everything else is like I don't know
how it works I don't know but I've I
know that I hate breastfeeding so I'm
all against it yeah yeah I none of my
friends were able to breastfeed they
were just like this is too this is
painful it's making me hate my baby it's
stressing me out right and the worst
thing for your baby is to be like okay
like that's worse than just yes you know
and it seems like everyone's on that
train I mean we just had a formula
shortage it seems like women are like
yup there's no shame in mothering
anything oh we have that we actually got
a diagram for you just so you know okay
thank you here it all breaks down for
you uh
is my boob
well mine is half under the muscle half
over the muscle is this like this so
yeah this is half over
half under no this is not good
it seems like you can though yeah you
can do it yeah yeah you can
thank you I'm assuming you got like now
what if I can't you know what I'm saying
a lot of women without fake boobs can't
breastfeed so I might not be able to but
that's nothing to do with the boots no
nothing I don't think so yeah
but did you get it like in like a back
room in Mexico or did you pay like a
nice I did do a couple I had to do a
couple so the first time I ever got
I talked about this in my last special
but I talked because in this special I
talked about my nudes getting leaked by
the way I wanted to give a shout out to
your special jokes on Netflix I wanted
to plug that thank you jokes on Netflix
guys go stream it and tell them who's
there thank you jokes ladies and
gentlemen it's just jokes it's jokes I'm
not lecturing anyone on how to vote it's
just jokes I'm not Netflix I'm not doing
jokes and then secretly gonna give a TED
Talk halfway through
behave like right okay fun fun fun
um and uh so so yeah so the when my news
leaked I talked a lot about like what
happens happened to my boobs with all of
the surgery but what the first time I
did it I I was because I had Eating
Disorders really bad and scoliosis
Growing Up So my boobs were different
sizes and I was always so embarrassed
about it like I had a bigger boob and a
smaller boob which most women's boots
are symmetrical that's normal yes and
hot remember Angelina Jolie's boobs and
Gia I do I actually commence
incredible I was a young man at that
time and she was like the hottest woman
sloppy and I was like damn bro I think I
watched that my brother
pirated it on a VHS tape and then he
would somehow he would on the VHS tape
replay the scene over and over I don't
know how he did it and it was on the VHS
State Department would repeat like 20
times when she was like play it out to
the elevator yeah yeah yeah and so yeah
I am very greatly familiar with that
people don't remember that that movie is
about a model that got AIDS we just
remember the boots that's it yeah yeah I
mean it sucks for sucks that that
happened but yeah look it is what it is
but um so I uh I basically you know as
soon as I started like making any money
I was like I just want to fix this
because I felt like so much of my body
dysmorphia and like body hatred was had
to do with like the fact that I was
always being reminded of being anorexic
and the eating disorder stuff so I was
like I just want like my boobs to like
be even so that I can just like you know
so I was too ashamed to ask anybody so I
basically just like like took a cab to
Beverly Hills walked up and down Roxbury
which is like a Street in Beverly Hills
it just has lots of like fancy doctors
and I just looked I found the first door
that said like cosmetic surgery and I
like walked upstairs and there was a man
that kind of looked like that guy that
was the oh yeah that impregnated all
those women and uh he was like his own
he was the surgeon but he was his own
like receptionist I love that but okay
great sign red flag look at him cutting
costs like he's very Hands-On this is
like you know and when you're in that
when you're committed to making a bad
decision you'll turn every red flag into
a green light you know it's like like
every guy dated I'm like they have four
DUIs they don't have a driver he's like
well he's a bad boy he's so green it's
so good for the environment he drives me
you know like you'll make it work and um
yeah he's married not afraid of
commitment like you'll find a way you
know so I get he's available the next
day to do the surgery wow no booking
none nothing on the calendar you want
that six month wait list yeah you don't
want the house tomorrow I can do it
tomorrow
by the way tomorrow morning oh great
where's your operating room just by LAX
okay truly off like like that that goes
to the airport I remember you're going
anesthesia I like heard planes I
you're about to get hit by so um so the
next uh I do the surgery and he did it
over the muscle and it turns out like he
used implants that were so small they
just look like dumb little like
Clementine like like they were and he
cut through a muscle oh my God I'll show
Ela like do you see how when I do that
you see yeah oh my God he cut through
the muscle he just cut right through it
yeah oh my God screwed up like you know
and so like wait for it to heal I was
too embarrassed to tell anyone and also
because for like the month after you're
not allowed to carry anything that's
over 10 pounds and I was too embarrassed
to tell anyone and I had a dog that was
that needed to go to the vet so I would
carry her you know like I was doing
stuff I wasn't supposed to be doing and
when you do that in uh the way the
doctor put it is it grinds up your
breast tissue to look like ground beef
all hardens if you don't let it just
heal properly so then I went to this guy
Fisher who's the guy he's like known for
he did Elle McPherson's boobs like he's
like allegedly
um and uh so I had to get two procedures
where he fixed it but what he does is he
does half over half under and while he
does a procedure he puts you on a
crucifix standing oh good wait you stand
up and he probably does it why that's
the real deal because that's your boobs
he needs to know how your boobs fall
that's actually the real mother loving
deal that's how you know the difference
of good and bad because and do while
you're lying down and blessed and your
fake tits have been blessed by Jesus in
the process he's watching he's always
watching always watching over so I told
him I was like can you please take a
picture of me hanging yeah I was gonna
ask do you have it you have it I cannot
give this to you oh that's that's very
professional that he won't even do it
I'll just find them on 410 buy them find
them final find them on is anyone up
yeah but yeah so so wait how long before
for the first procedure and the second
procedure uh like four years five years
and so what was the four years like
living with the first ones was it
horrible or was it fine it wasn't
horrible because I was like I was
definitely proud of myself for because I
was I was so like toxically the word
isn't feminist but like you have to
accept your body and like you know but
if you're doing it for you it's okay
like but I had the stuff in my head that
like if you do anything cosmetic to your
body or fix a deformity or something
like you're a bad role model to women
like I just put all this pressure on
myself so I was at least like proud that
I was like okay I took a step to like
make myself happier in this area and
worked it helped a little bit at the
time I was again I was like too skinny
at the time and I didn't want to be
skinny anymore and I was like I just
need my body to fit into
the body that genetically all the women
in my family have okay so that I can
just live that you know like I have big
hips I haven't like I like that about
myself you know and then Garth Fisher
was like yeah your boobs should be a d
wide not a DL I didn't know I didn't
even know I never learned about bra
sizes or any of that stuff like I never
so he made it wider because they were
just so separate and so far apart and so
um one was higher than the other what
was the joke I did last special it was
like um uh one was Alec Baldwin and one
was Stephen Baldwin I just wanted two
Alex yeah for he before the before yeah
that's a great joke hey what did you
think
you were going to say I do have a
question because you're mentioning that
you had
um Eating Disorders you look super
healthy today I think and how did you
get out of that mindset like is it still
something that you always have to deal
with or do you completely recover and
it's I'm sure it's different for
everyone from what I understand uh in
what I believe
um is that you for the rest of your life
you have on some level disordered eating
which just means you know it doesn't
have to be over pathologized you just
have to know that about yourself you you
just have to know about yourself when
you start losing control in some areas
of your life you seek control in other
areas like whack-a-mole so as I get
older it used to really be with food now
it's with like cleaning my house and
watering the yard I get in this place
where I'm like if I don't I'll get up at
like 12 30 at night be like if I just
water the yard everything's gonna be
fine instead of just like checking my
emails and like doing the things I need
to do it used to be with food it was
just like a preoccupation where I felt
like I could control something that was
the addiction so if you know that about
yourself it might manifest in other ways
it might you know you might be like get
the food under control you know you're
eating a sleeve of Oreos in your car
secretly every day or something and then
you get that under control and then all
of a sudden you're shopping too much and
returning it or you know you're
shoplifting or you're gambling or you're
doing online playing video games like
watching Game of Thrones 12 episodes a
day you know like it comes up other ways
so you can definitely switch that
addictive behavior to another thing an
old masquerade is something else but it
always is the same route of like the
need to control and anesthetize for me
it was a big isolation thing too I had
so much Social Anxiety that I would sort
of subconsciously like binge on food so
then I would have to like go to the gym
or I'd make myself sick and then I could
like cancel plans and not see anyone I
would like incapacitate myself it's I
think that like I guess when you hear
about people that are addicted to
alcohol or drugs like they're kind of
trying to remove themselves from reality
or not have to be there or not have to
care as much while they're there like
for me it was a way to just remove
myself and go like well I'm too sick to
go out like I'm in fetal position I
would eat like like really viscous like
like protein bars that you know the ones
that are just like like sludge they're
just like a hard hard sludge like Power
Bars but when you take the wrapper off
the indent of the wrapper is there yeah
you know like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
like nine or two like what is that made
of like what is that
um and so I would eat like five or six
thousand I would get so sick I wouldn't
have to go anywhere and that was a
relief for me to not have to like
socialize or like see people so I had to
heal a lot of that like so for me I had
to do like you know I know I talk about
all the time I'm in a 12-step program
called Al-Anon adult child of Alcoholics
where you like sort of just like figure
out what your compulsive behaviors are
from from the [ __ ] that went wrong in
your childhood and figuring out like
what hole you're trying to fill fill it
other ways you know and have you found
like a healthy outlet for that
for uh like you know yeah I think for me
like being of service is a big thing
like I I don't know if it's healthy the
dog rescuing thing and the animal rescue
thing what's wrong with that I had an
ear bitten off like all this happened
over the pandemic this thumb I can't I
mean
I was fostering a dog that was super
handicapped and another foster dog went
to attack it and I just like put my hand
oh I knew it was gonna be bad I did it
with my leg I did it with that this
finger too wow so I have a lot of but
it's a really good thing you do I mean
you saved you you really saved us one
night yeah I don't know if I told this
story on the podcast before we may have
but I just can tell it again I was crazy
we were driving around just having like
a Pleasant Drive uh around uh Bel Air
somewhere cold water yeah cold water and
there was like we saw two big ass dogs
running around huge difference at night
huge German Shepherds it was like 12
o'clock and I was like oh [ __ ] and
you're like you're driving past and
you're like I I gotta help the dog I
didn't see it I didn't see it there's an
owner there's an owner you try to
convince yourself you're like someone
else will deal with that and you're like
or like the owner is here somewhere yeah
and I love my dog so if if you know if
somebody found one of my dogs running
around the street and called me I'd be
like [ __ ] kiss their savior I mean
yeah so so I have that level of empathy
for doggo you guys could tell you have
such good instincts it was clear that
those were someone's dogs oh yeah you
can tell I mean they're beautiful dogs
they have collars so I get out I'm
chasing this dog around this
neighborhood at night oh Shredder was in
the car by the way though right yeah
yeah and you brought one of them out and
the dog that was bad all free because
because we were like what do we do we
realized okay the two dogs are
somebody's and this person is not here
so like what do we do and then at one
point we thought can we take them with
us but we have the two dogs with us and
it's like how do we get everybody to get
along because you know that's a whole
thing yes and they were big and our dogs
are small so that's another these were
giant German Shepherds and I know I'm
gonna get in a lot of trouble for this
as someone that is the Pitbull owner I'm
not going to generalize about dogs but
German Shepherds if they make a mistake
there's no
like there's no Second Chance dude I
feel honestly I feel like an idiot
because I really put Shredder in danger
and I'm glad he wasn't hurt but
sometimes I think about it could have
gone sideways because I was really
sideways yeah I was petting these dogs I
was trying to become friendly with them
and they would basically say Hi and then
run off but they seem friendly so I was
like okay by the way the one thing that
pissed me off the most I finally get
this dog calm enough I get his caller it
has a QR code I'm like these [ __ ]
[ __ ] a QR code and it was too dark
and so we couldn't catch it on on the
camera of the phone yeah yeah and then
so I'm trying to the worst about this
I've got like the new Saint Bernard's
like um Barrel
I don't know what you are remember you
know Saint Bernard the dogs that are the
rescue dogs that they send out oh yeah
they have the little stuff like water
yes
uh no it's not like that dog people
don't look at that
um so I was just trying to get a legible
picture of the QR code at night and
after like an hour I finally got it I
clicked the QR code and it goes no
profile
it didn't work or something it was so
annoying I don't even know what that
even mean you shouldn't be asking
strangers to get that close to your dog
exactly so dangerous it was so hard to
get it and he was trying so hard and
meanwhile our dogs are barking because
they're like what's happening so I mean
with them in the car they're barking
non-stop like we really wanted to help
and that thing made it impossible
so [ __ ] pissed at the owners because
it's like you put the collar on it
doesn't say anything yeah I'm running
around trying to catch your [ __ ] dogs
and you wouldn't even put the you're in
your phone number you know what else
pissed me off I could have hit your dogs
and I would have had to live with that
like that also pisses me off like you'll
feel yes your dogs are gonna die with it
without me because you have no idea what
you're doing and you you shouldn't have
these dogs you don't know what you're
doing you know like if you know he had
just moved into it this is the story I
got okay it was he just moved into that
house and the dogs got out I think it's
inexcusable if you have that much money
and you live in that neighborhood have a
hire someone to watch your dogs yeah he
was like a super [ __ ] Rich Super Rich
money guy but one of these like VC guys
where it's very unclear if the money's
real or if it's a coin or ethereum
rupees
or what it is like it's unclear but I
can't get a hold of him I can't get a
hold of him I'm calling the shelter if
if I I If by the time I call you connect
to you
if you don't call me back within like
three or four hours if your dogs are
missing yeah what the [ __ ] don't worry
man look at me don't call it should be
three minutes because I go I'm like you
should if you're like oh my god I've
been looking everywhere yeah you're fine
yeah but if you're just like oh yeah I
heard they were out like you should know
so then I went full not this that word
on him you bitched him out I just was
like what are you doing man like I was
like this better be an incredible
explanation or you're not getting your
dogs packed it's not it's nothing
personal I just I'm I'm killing them if
I return them to you yeah right like you
just you know yeah and so um he was like
we just moved this neighborhood and I
had just rescued them and they had never
been to this house and they got scared
because I left like his explanation was
pretty good and I was like okay well now
what are we gonna do about the fact that
these dogs destroyed my garage door
destroyed my garage door because I put
them in my garage because I had to just
put them somewhere for a couple hours I
didn't want to Crate them in case they
freaked out or tried to open the door
and choke themselves or something that
happens a lot and if they're scared so
the entire inside of my door is
destroyed I'll send you a picture and
then they had locked themselves in so
they're jumping locked up then I had to
uh I think we have a video of me
smashing the windows of my garage yes to
crawl in and then I I keep texting the
guy I'm like hey it's gonna be like two
grand to cover this he was like I'll
cover the damage whatever it's like two
thousand dollars and I can't get him to
respond about it yeah and I'm like you
know I don't need I don't care it's just
more weird did he ever compensate you I
I like I don't even wanna you know what
I mean did he I just don't I just it's
the you know what it is if you do that
it is your responsibility to follow up
yes well hold on you're rich so it's not
yours yeah so you don't want to have to
like chase him for it of course it's
ridiculous I just I never paid you for
that what a [ __ ] you didn't make an
effort to follow up
someone did that for my animals I would
be like what can I do please tell me
yeah you can hang off yourself I'll be
your slave for a week
dude what a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] I tell
you the next day his driver came and
picked them up
this is what it was and I remember
seeing the driver I was like dude I have
no problem with you but like your boss
is whack like he's like oh like you sent
a driver to come get your dogs like it
was just was a bummer dude what a dick
but I feel better because they were like
a bonded pair and I'm like yeah they
have each other two together German
Shepherds are fine when they're just
with each other the thing was my vibe on
the dogs
was that he just wanted some guard dogs
because it wasn't a gated community
right because it's a big house and I
think he I don't think he gives a [ __ ]
about the dogs probably the housekeepers
take care of him and he just has them
there or they even lived outside just as
guard dogs yeah and and you know just
jumped the fence and they were they were
sweethearts but the part where so
basically I had exhausted all the
options when I found them on the street
the QR code didn't work I didn't know
what to do and so I was like maybe if I
bring Shredder out because he's
generally really good with other dogs
then um
we can start making a relationship and
get them in the car yeah so that we can
all go and take them with us because
also this was a street with lots of cars
and we were it was super dark and we
were like they're gonna get you know 50
miles an hour yeah and they would keep
like they'll come to us and then run off
you know so we were like the longer we
wait here they're gonna get hit or
something and now it's blood on your
hands and I was like I I have that this
is it was like 12 30 at night when you
guys yeah yeah it was [ __ ] up and you
know
I wasn't just gonna leave them there and
that's and I think that's also part of
the reason like that I just got in the
car right away not only are you guys
real friends of mine but also I was like
I know their heart they have such big
hearts they're gonna get their dogs
killed trying to help these freaking
dogs did you know I was like I know you
guys aren't gonna leave until someone
handles this like and you're gonna put
your dogs in danger so it was so scary
so I took Shredder out
and he was going towards him and doing a
little sniffing and then both these huge
German Shepherds are smelling them and
then one of them goes for a knit and I
pick Shredder up real fast and I'm
pulling them up on my hand and then I
thought it got your finger he did he did
by the way the guy didn't give a [ __ ]
about that too
that's can I tell you I just had to get
a rabie shot I have to go get my fourth
one today I had to get a rabies vaccine
I was uh a couple weeks ago Andrew
Schultz was on the podcast so we had
like I drank a little bit that night I
like went to bed late uh I hadn't let
the dogs out
um like I always like to just let them
out every couple hours we have a new
puppy a little pitbull puppy and so like
4am I just opened the door to let the
dogs out instantly I just hear like a
whoa scuffle just like a melee of just
like an animal and I'm like oh god there
were coyotes outside and let the dogs
outside and I just I just put my hands
out to try to just separate them to just
kind of do that they were fighting with
a coyote it was three raccoons it was a
mom mom two babies oh my God and then I
looked down I see a raccoon and I was
like [ __ ] I literally because it was
like um you know what I thought I saw
that you know the little guy from Shrek
that is like the little like thing in
the suit yeah it looked like that like
it was just so and then I felt one run
up my leg and grab my
and so I go inside and then I get the
dogs in everything's fine wow they go up
in the tree and I was like I was like I
thought I was having a heart attack I
was like yeah I have a heart attack like
that's fine like a little young for this
but like fair and I like couldn't
breathe my dude is a veterinarian and he
came downstairs and he was like you're
going like right now to the yard to get
uh uh and I was like oh it's fine like
and I think this is another way that
social media or Instagrams we're looking
to get us killed or Tick Tock is because
any dangerous animal in the world you
can find someone on Tick Tock or
Instagram who has it as a pet yes he
sent me videos like that all the time no
I I see all these raccoons like
snuggling up with their owners and in my
head like raccoons just my recent memory
of them is that they're adorable and
they love humans and they're super so
I'm just like it's fine they're just
like it was just scared you know and he
was like you're going and then because I
had some scratches on my arms and stuff
and then I call Animal Control the next
day the videos of this raccoon will show
you they're still nuts it was like
hanging over the tree I poked it and it
wouldn't really move it was moving
really slow which is not normal that's
very abnormal this is prep after the
fight the raccoon was injured next day I
just and were your dogs okay they I
think yeah they're fine they had their
rabies shots and stuff but then I call
animal control because that is what
you're you do have to do you have to get
it off your property you know if it has
is sick especially if it has rabies
rabies will kill you I think it's the
most deadly virus I kind of thought it
just made you a grump no it's like
almost impossible to survive like you
just die in agonizing pain like almost
for certain yes yeah I don't think I
knew that like I don't [ __ ] horrible
it's weird that and you don't think
about rabies and then when I went to the
ER they were like we've never seen this
with a raccoon only with bats that's
good but this is what happens that's
[ __ ] up too this is what animal
control said I was like first of all
this is California Animal Control I was
like you guys there's the raccoon in my
tree it looks like it's just like sick
or like really lethargic and she goes
well it's probably sleeping and I was
like well no I mean it's okay and I was
like well it's up in this tree she's
like yeah that's where they live I'm not
gonna remove a rectum from its home
sorry it's okay I got a cute raccoon
video
then this is what she said she said in
La a lot of people are testing their
cocaine for fentanyl if it tests
positive they flush it down the toilet
so there's a lot of fentanyl in LA water
system so the raccoon would probably
just drank it say what what she's
telling me that the wild animals in
California are on fentanyl oh my God
Municipal Water
where's my [ __ ] euphoric great
question you hydrate more
yeah more government water people are
going
call your dad and get the apology you
never got like if you're testing your
cocaine how much
how hard do you need to look at the
mirror okay so was it just sleeping I
don't know we came home my my vet my
boyfriend and vet was like we need to
catch it so that I can cut its head off
oh and test it for rabies yeah that's
what I think too that's what you're
supposed to do but it was gone by the
time we got home and then I now have the
rabies sex probably eat
it might have been eaten or the mom just
took it back and they're just oh it was
a baby yeah they're just like just yeah
raccoons are pretty Scrappy they're
they're scary dude but they're very like
they can stand up and like walk on two
legs here look at this they're straight
up they're Critters but they're tough
little guys
um they're so cute yeah they're really
suspiciously all those little critters
are super cute man Even Rats are like
super cute
no no I don't think they don't have a
backbone so they can just curl into
balls see yeah yeah that is so cute but
if he was up against a pit bull that
doesn't seem like a he would fear my
dogs better they don't want for you they
just want to protect so they just were
like they were just barking at them and
then everyone I think just kind of
panicked that is so cute this is amazing
there's a lot of videos of them like
jerking off oh for real okay shout out
right so on on that note on the Raccoon
note um we're way over our time to do
that I have one ad let me just blast
through this real fast
thank you to hello fresh for sponsoring
this episode you know them you love them
all Super Troopers love hellofresh
get farm fresh pre-portioned ingredients
and seasonal recipes delivered right to
your doorstep skip the trips to the
grocery store
and count on hellofresh to make home
cooking easy fun and affordable that's
why it's America's number one meal kit
let's show Whitney the
pull up the uh the burrito
I want to get your take on this burrito
all this food looks delicious of course
hella fresh I love hella fresh so but
but here now what do you think of this
that's you know what I like a grill I
like knowing it's going to be crispy And
Pastry on the outside that was submitted
by a b that's very pretty it's a
gorgeous burrito as long as it's not
cold on the inside I'm in no it was warm
but that burriti you would oh yeah but
you don't even know what's in it anyway
shout out
um listen guys
skip the grocery store and spend more
time soaking up the Summer sun hello
Fresh Market is a One-Stop shop for all
your mealtime needs with quick breakfast
lunch snacks desserts and more it's a
foolproof step-by-step recipes means a
joyful cooking experience with a
stress-free summer Plus
customize your favorite dishes with
hello custom
oh I mean Hello Fresh Cuts I mean I mean
hello Fred custom
by swapping out one protein or side for
another here's my blow your mind hello
fresh is 72 percent cheaper than dining
at a restaurant and even cheaper than
any grocery shopping
that's money back in your pocket our
everybody in the community loves Hello
fresh shoes or submitted by Hoopa
Troopers
and uh it looks amazing looks delicious
go to hellofresh.com impressive yeah I
know it is uh go to hellofresh.com after
dark16 and use the God after dark 16 for
16 free meals across seven boxes and
three free gifts
I love fresh America's number one veal
kit
thank you thank you
yeah so anyway
um
so just going back to finish my story
was that I put Shredder out to say hi
and then it was going okay and then they
started to nip at him and I they got it
they got a chunk of him and I it got
picked him up super fast and put them up
like this and then they started jumping
you know how dogs jump off you and I was
like dude please God I was so [ __ ]
the fact that they didn't bite your face
yeah that could have gone so many ways
it dude yeah I got so lucky because I
just I was holding him like this and
just walking backwards they were running
around me trying to jump yeah yeah
better and I was just walking slowly
back to the car Ila's window was cracked
I just threw him in the car and I'm just
so [ __ ] lucky facial scars are cool
late like they're not cool they're cool
when you've got them as a kid and have
them now it's not cool to be like in
your 30s and have it be like yeah it's
gonna look cool in like 10 years you
know what I mean they would have they
would have killed a shredder so fast I
was just so scared but anyway after that
happened we caught we were like I don't
know what to do but I was like I know
Whitney's always like yeah
no I always see you you know dealing
with dogs or with rescue and stuff like
that so I was like she's the only person
I can think of and she would know what
to do so yeah we reached out to you and
then obviously you she immediately came
to get them and that was amazing and as
soon as you got there you knew what to
do you had the treats you're like come
on dogs get in the car I always have
like jerky in my car I have a rope I
have a net I have like ever but I had
and I was like okay based on what you
told me it was so funny because it was
so me I was like walk to the fridge grab
some another keys and got in the car
yeah dude they got in you knew exactly
what to do they were like [ __ ] this I'm
like straight into her car yeah I
literally jumped in the back seat you're
like all right well I can't hear them
forever yeah I know I I like I do I'm
not great with people but I'm very good
with them like I'm kind of like you know
I I I I
never want to say the word that would
get us in trouble and for some reason
today now that I can't I know like Works
in every possible scenario
um yeah see you next Tuesday right yeah
yeah can I ask you a question uh that I
forgot to ask and I know I text you
about it how come when I was going to
doing my stand-up shows for a while a
lot of your fans thought I was doing
Frenemies
oh oh I think there was a gag or
something where I think what happened I
think people wanted you to people wanted
yeah on the sub ready uh after a
Frenemies broke up a lot of people oh
we're bringing you up as a suggestion
and you wanted people to guess who it
was I but didn't I do something by
accident that like oh yes I posted like
you did you were wearing people thought
you were sending it and it was liminal I
can't remember now I'm like blanking out
what is happening yeah my feet started
like blowing up with all this stuff yeah
and so I remember what happened so we
had were teasing that we had a
replacement it was my mom it was just a
gag yeah and we did like a short series
with my mom replacing Trisha but I think
that combined with your post that was
like uh was it like black we have black
and pink posts or something it was yeah
we have it right here so people were
like oh you know what it was my special
art came out and oh it's like the
Frenemies back so they're like yo she's
in the studio half pink half black yeah
that's so weird
oh so that looks exactly like the studio
it does yeah
super crazy coincidence and and
everybody already wanted us to find like
a different hostel they were always
bringing up people they would want to
see yeah so people bring it up a lot and
I was like I just didn't know what I was
walking into or what I stepped into
you know yeah like a whole thing
interesting did you ever think about
like because it's interesting when I'm
looking back at like Network TV when
they audition new hosts like remember
like Kelly Ripa did it where you know I
remember when Ferguson went off the air
like I hosted for a while Adam Pali
hosted for a while Ben Schwartz like
like that's always like an interesting
right press play like the view always
gets like such big numbers when they
have new homes
you know what
I haven't done that I just don't know if
I could ever replace Trisha it was just
lightning in a bottle yeah yeah it's
true no like you gotta know when to call
I would love to you know I've thought
about it it would be the top five it's
just a fun game to play top five like
who would be if you had to gone to your
head okay let's see uh let me think
top five would be
um here let me see people women craziest
great see if there's a list
it's gonna be like
you and Amber Heard yeah Amber Heard
would be interesting for sure Rosa Parks
that's here uh what Rosie bar yeah Tana
Tana would be good tandem Mojo
potentially uh man on next week I wanted
to vet her a little bit and I invited
her to just come on the show and then
she she said she wanted to and then she
gusted me so here's what I love about
her I mean I I like her like I I just
know kind of like a weird amount about
her because I helped Josh Richards write
roast jokes for the Bryce Hall Rose you
know the the YouTube kids like yeah
seemed me to help write jokes so I had
to write all these jokes about uh Tana
Mojo and I fell so in love with her with
how not sensitive she is you know what I
mean like I used to I used to have
Comedy Central roast and like Pam
Anderson was there and you do all these
rough jokes and people get upset or like
we're play fighting like you're not
allowed to have feelings like it's what
we're doing and uh we wrote Such Savage
jokes about her just like occur you know
and she was cool about it she laughed
that's good she wasn't like she had it
yeah no she's she's not sense she's a
good sense of humor a lot of people say
a lot of crazy [ __ ] about air online and
I don't it doesn't seem to bother her at
all it was like Josie Canseco Tana Mojo
I don't know that's not can I ask you a
question on the topic of roast sure so
um what's her name uh she looked uh
what's her name the other there's a
there's a woman comedian who's Joan
Rivers uh no she's big right now
and uh a roaster Nikki Glazer uh Amy
Schumer yeah Amy Schumer so she I know
like you say it's play fighting so I
wonder where the LA if there is a line
in roasting that you that maybe is too
far because she famously did this joke
when they were roasting Stevo after Ryan
Dunn had died and she's like uh we miss
Ryan Dunn but I'll say what we're all
thinking why did it have to be him and
not you or something to that effect
right and and everyone I see people
bring that up all the time as like she
was [ __ ] she went too far with that
joke and I just I always wondered like
really I don't know at a roast there's
no such thing as twofold that's what I
thought but if she walked out the door
and did it all of a sudden it's mean but
in the context of a roast there's no
such thing as too far I thought like
obviously it was super [ __ ] up but
like that's the whole point I but she
gets a lot of [ __ ] for that joke and I
just don't really but that's interesting
I think the part that crushed her was
that Stevo looked like he was laughing
and laughing and then he was like
that that is that's hard so usually the
producer will make sure that you don't
not for anyone so the comedians don't
look like bullies for no reason like I
think a lot of times they switch out the
reaction shots like when we did or dirty
as [ __ ] though there was something that
was uh who was that that we did that
Carrot Top was on and he like was like
seemed very emotional like you see we
were kind of like oh God we need to pull
back like Carrot Top you know first of
all he's the nicest guy he works so hard
and he's you know he's not like with
comedians every night so who knows if he
still has that thick skin of like always
being roasted in The Green Room he's
kind of sequestered in Vegas like his
props and batons or whatever you know
that show's incredible he does it ever
scared
yeah he's actually you know I know he
gets a lot of [ __ ] for being a prop
comedian but I've seen he's actually
pretty funny dude a prop implies that
you're using a crutch maybe sometimes
literally instead of delivering a joke
or instead of you're being sloppy and
taking a shortcut when you see his show
there's like fire and he's doing
backflips like this guy's not being lazy
you can't accuse him of that yeah you
know so but again it's like Jeff Dunham
I hate Jeff Dunham okay
I'm just gonna put that out there
I have a one-sided beef with Jeff Dunham
that's so funny yeah I've been beefing
with Jeff Dunham since the beginning of
my channel but he doesn't no he has no
idea actually you should get a puppet of
Jeff Dunham we didn't you did yeah we've
we've got we've exhausted every Avenue
of Jeff Dunham
uh slander
so what was what's your main beef I mean
I I can guess but well I used to make
jokes about how like his he he did these
jokes to the puppets that like were
super racist and I was like he's super
[ __ ] racist but nobody cares because
it's the [ __ ] puppet right like he's
got the jalapeno that talks like there's
other Mexican stereotypes and he's like
whoa there jalapen you know it's like
you're saying it it's not the jalapeno
that's saying the racist Mexican it's
you Jeff Dunham and he's like this
wholesome like hey I'm just a good old
boy it's like no you're a [ __ ] racist
piece of [ __ ] I bet but I don't like his
act either also he's kind of a hack this
I don't mean this as an insult in any
way it's more General I bet he doesn't
even know like you guys could probably
have him as a guest and just never you
would never know like that one more like
a funny everyone would be in it totally
up to him you would have no idea unless
you never bring it up he would have no
clue I feel like that would be kind of
amazing
the undead Terrace I mean this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] but here's okay this is how old
it is this was one maybe like some of
our first videos ever it was back in
Israel when we were living together in
Israel American Hero is he big over like
in other countries yeah it is yeah
interesting you know what's kind of
crazy about Jeff Dunham he's like the
it's like one of the biggest comedians
comedians in the world yeah I think yeah
I knew that yeah because pouring is wild
because you can bring kid
yes you can't now the because you're my
kids right yeah no that's family
friendly but it's like hey
let's go bomb the new World Trade Center
if you were better whoa I'm doing that
too maybe did you see the Abercrombie
Fitch documentary yeah I loved it dude
what the hell remember those shirts dude
really you do okay because I don't I I
didn't even live here back then so I've
only like I've seen their stores I think
when they were already kind of like on
the way out but they were still sort of
maybe cool I don't know when I first
came to America when I lived in like
Virginia West Virginia like DC area
people would be wearing those it would
look like a Chinese food Carton and it
was like wildly racist you look back can
you pull up some of those yeah Abby
carvery Finch there was a documentary
did you see like they're just like their
manual for the company and how they
would like say like this if somebody
looks like that they can't work
basically like a black person can't work
or they also we really did would hire a
black person and then never give them
shifts yeah she would work in the back
only yeah
so crazy yeah this is my dream guest
right here and we're saying new
Frenemies host oh a new friend Aries I
just want his puppy I want to drop it so
he's out only me and the spicy jalapeno
can I ask you a weird question
with every comedian yeah you can kind of
Trace back like a trauma
right yeah like you know when like
Colbert I remember being like how did he
get funny he's so nice and someone's
like oh yeah super tragic half his
family died in a plane crash yeah yeah
yeah yeah I can't wait I didn't like his
dad
something where you're like I can't even
process yeah like wouldn't be surprised
if he hasn't even thought about it since
it happened you know what so Jeff Dunham
must have had something bad happened to
him to decide to like put his hand in a
in a puppet
he did that
throwing them like it's
wrong
we can find out but by the way these are
the racist uh uh walking Bowl
Abercrombie and by the way in addition
to this the photographer was like trying
to sleep with the guy yeah straight up
like like
sexually assaulting modeled which by the
way you should have wild that no one
cares if it's a guy very very
problematic no one marches like no one
cares about the church everyone's like
oh yeah that's no the little boys no one
cares they still don't care I'm like
people think it's funny people go I I
can't I can't stand it people go
John podesto a pedophile conspiracy uh
uh uh Hillary Clinton i'm like [ __ ] the
Catholic church is literally still
raping kids little boys if a Hollywood
actress someone hugs her too long
everything shuts down we shut down
everyone is we don't go to work like
everything stops we change laws but when
young boys are being molested no one
cares yeah and it's that that crime is
so damaging too because men are have
such a hard time expressing stuff and
then they end up uh well I had a joke
about this because they're so [ __ ] up
for that like there's no charity and
then I I was trying to work on a joke
about this about like you know the
closest thing to any sort of rehab they
have for this is uh Alcoholics Anonymous
and you know that's probably true take
place in a church like how traumatic to
have to like oh my gosh um
and when a priest molest the kid and
they send them to the Vatican and
they're they just they they just send
them to a new oh yeah because they can't
be prosecuted there yeah they protect
them or they send them to a another
Community or relocate did they send them
in the Vatican because there's no law
there and they're protected they're
Sovereign yeah and I was I was thinking
I was like uh a joke about like look I
don't want a molest a kid but like if I
get a free trip to Italy like just don't
like at least don't give them an
incentive oh that's [ __ ] um right
there you know in the Vatican they
probably have like uh
you know you watch a vampire movie and
they have like all these humans like
cattle and they're like this is our
perfect vampire Society yeah so I'm
assuming in the Vatican they just have a
big old room of kids little boys they
just line them up little dicks like
lined up well that's the thing that I
think this is probably going to get us
in trouble me in trouble at least
um I think part of the reason no one
will talk about it is because the word
molestation is so vague like if you when
you hear it you then have to picture
what you think it is and then you're the
weirdo does that make sense like no one
wants to pass I think nobody talks about
it because it is very often people are
afraid to talk about
the church the Catholic church because
they're going to be seen asleep at
church I was just thinking because we
were talking about documentaries that
you know gymnastics were really bad
um there's we watched that one about uh
Brian the singer right that's his name
dude
oh my God it made us so upset afterwards
you see these kids that he ruined their
life what was that though they're just
so traumatized now as adults and like he
just recently learned their lives so
what did like it was were they underage
underage they were sent to Hollywood you
know the Big Break whatever and
completely taken advantage Open Secret I
think it's called oh really and um it
ruins their life I mean yeah and they
had like a whole uh grooming procedure
where they would like they so
parties with like young kids that's the
thing that I always I'm like I'm always
like agents like that's what no one
talks about like how do you think all
these people were sent to these hotel
rooms how do you think like all like you
know because when people like how come
there's not more diversity in Hollywood
it's like it's only as diverse as the
agent's sign because you know what I'm
saying because the agents are say here's
who's available here's who can you know
like otherwise you're just dming people
and you're also not allowed to ask
people they're sex they're race they're
age or any of that so it's like how are
you you're not allowed to ask so you
can't say like hey I need a black
lighting guy like that's illegal like
you can't do that so it's like no one
thinks about the agent's impact on all
this that's so odd yeah so he was a
manager that would recruit like
hot young boys cool job his words not
mine yeah yeah and uh he would basically
groom them and become so well familiar
with their family he would start
molesting them and then once like they
were marked you know as like he would
bring them to Brian Singer had these
huge parties and they would have like a
bunch of their friends over they were
taking drugs ecstasy stuff and they
would bring these kids to the party and
uh take advantage of these young boys
there and the crazy thing is yeah this
is called an Open Secret it's really
good but very disturbing the thing is
Brian Singer everybody knew this guy was
a straight [ __ ] pedo uh rapist and he
was he literally just got like he's not
getting work anymore he did he was the
he did X-Men big movies yeah huge movies
in fact in fact sometimes I just trip
out looking at um his IMDb here he is
Brian Singer
and the thing is everybody knew what
this guy was and if you look at his IMDb
like here's let's see what's his most
recent X-Men in 2014 look at all these
massive [ __ ] actors that are working
with him I mean there's a new wait for a
new one no no this was in 2014. it is
crazy to think Mel Gibson has like 15
movies in production I know it's not the
same crimes but if you get raped by a
pack of did you know he said that my
Lakers tickets that guy is so nuts man
like just like wild I think that
Hollywood gives a pass to alcoholism
don't you think yeah if it was under
drunk we're like okay that didn't happen
like you know which always makes me
think because I'm still at a place in my
life where I'm like does alcohol change
who you are or reveal Who You Are
yeah
right money success alcohol
reveals who you are I'm trying to that's
sad
thanks I'm trying to find what
his most recent work was but this can't
be right did you see the Woody Allen
documentary oh my god dude I [ __ ]
can't yes I did yeah can we also just
talk about how his movies aren't that
good
The Usual Suspects yeah wasn't that
brand singer that's right we moved on to
Woody Allen Woody Allen's movies aren't
good I don't think they're funny I don't
like to see a man I've never really
watched them dice
spiders scare me like cool like and why
are all the women only wearing khaki
shorts from
Aeropostale like and by the way in one
of the Annie Hall is it where he's
trying to [ __ ] uh I mean in general no
that's uh that's Manhattan Manhattan no
yeah and then in real life he flew to
her home uh Mariel Heming away yeah I
think so Miriam
we don't what are we doing yeah he
married his stepdaughter what are we
doing a daughter that he raised himself
you know
you know daughter why are we
I don't know personally no no I don't
know that HBO documentary is like done
done his own daughter said this happened
to me and they have so many people that
are familiar with them and have seen it
you know it's not like a one person like
he said she said and they're arguing
yeah there's like everybody that was
around the family knew about it they had
to keep the daughter away from him
because he would get weird with her like
what dude he that's what the most [ __ ]
up how much more information do you guys
need like what else but there's
something interesting about our
Collective need to defend too because
it's just too painful or too
we've invested too much time in this
person so we have to yeah people love
Woody Allen I'm not one of those people
but people really love Woody Allen yeah
and so it really but here's the here's
what I'll say I also think though that
whatever personality Persona character
that he is now that you look at it in
retrospect and it's about like
inoculating yourself like who me it all
now feels more it feels weirdly more
predatory when someone is like I'm not a
predator I can't even get laid and no
one wants to have sex with me like that
to me makes it weird it's like why was
no one like why does Michael Jackson
have elephants in the backyard oh this
was my favorite by the way Brian Singer
made Bohemian Rhapsody in 2018
2018. you got fired halfway through
though right that's the left halfway
that's the one I think that was halfway
through I think yes I think you're right
credit it as director but I'm like you
all knew and [ __ ] like huge actors
this ship won an Academy Award didn't it
but do you think there's something to
all the really talented canceled people
being forced to make like a super movie
and donate of course there's a lot of
really very talented perverts Woody
Allen Brian Woody I don't think he's
funny I don't know I'm good on that
Brett Ratner Brett Ratner Harvey's not
allowed to out but he does the Final Cut
he'll do that
who's Brett Ratner Brett Ratner he did
rush hour right he did what did he do
and here's a problem I don't even
remember like at this point let's find
out no he the LA Times
let's see what uh he has allegations
from Olivia
but he but she said that I'm sorry he
claimed that she slept with him which
was not true but that's there was Elliot
page said something that he say to her
as sexually assaulted her her that's
what she's her I mean him sorry yeah wow
I said Elliot page and then yeah but I
guess you know what I'll just say my
defense it she was at the time Brian
Singer would have
molested him yeah now she he is equal
opportunity yeah yeah
I like that I mean that's nice
that's how you get ahead in Hollywood
you're like a whole new group of people
are going to want to pray yeah that's
how you get it
um and then who else so who else Scott
Rudin Fred Savage Oh Fred Savage okay
Roman Polanski is he still alive he's in
I've never yeah he did Rosemary's Baby I
don't think we need him for this
particular project you have a very
specific like I I feel like mine he
seems I don't know he doesn't have
enough compunction for Mike we need to
manage
the arrogance who else by the way did
you see Alec Baldwin interview
is that a [ __ ] is it wild wild ride
or what I well yeah he was just dick
riding him and having like absolute the
utmost respect and reverence for him I'm
obsessed with Alec Baldwin for so many
reasons it's hard to like have any
idea he's so goddamn endearing I had a
project with Alec Baldwin like four
years ago I was playing his daughter it
didn't pan out
dodge a bullet
literally
but I love him the more picky things he
does the more I like him I can't even
explain it like it makes no sense it's
like my daddy issues or something like I
read his book before I was going to work
with him have you read it like like uh
Serendipity it's like something he's
like like black and white cover he talks
[ __ ] about everyone he's worked with oh
really I believe everyone's not talking
about this book really and it to me
seemed very clear that he's still in
love with Kim Basinger like today he
will bring her up randomly like for no
reason he'll be like you know they've
been divorced for 20 years I feel like
it was a cold night but not as cold as
Kim's heart like what like
so dramatic and he still writes more
chapters on his Facebook page like
regularly nevertheless like like
regularly that's like writes new chap
but um does he have like you know that
he's a podcast does he have like 10 kids
now like what's the comment so many but
he did on my podcast Adam television on
my podcast and Adam Pally said that he
saw uh uh Alec Baldwin on that show
match game he's recording it and he was
like oh you gotta congratulations you
got another kid and uh Alec Baldwin
I ain't [ __ ] her so I don't know
whose it is oh my what that's pretty
funny I don't know who's [ __ ] her
because it ain't me it was like
something like that I was like Jesus
right you know he said six hits with her
he's been on houses always great we're
up to seven now yeah have you seen the
videos of her when she's got the accent
yes I've heard about it we've done the
whole thing incredible yeah she has like
a fake it's super weird she put on like
this fake Latino accent yeah Latina
accent and then people are like dude
you're born in America you're like
American he was pretending like she was
Spanish
uh she's just like you're from New
Jersey when are we gonna cancel people
for that aren't from England having
English accents is that a thing yeah
call them out name like Madonna kind of
dog it oh really actress when they go on
a talk show all of a sudden they're kind
of like from Troy can you do it no no
um but yeah there was that that um I
don't know if you guys ever saw the show
The Comeback I think it's the funniest
comedy ever made but Lisa Kudrow said
she kind of based it on one at one
specific sort of actress or an amalgam
of a bunch of actresses in their worst
behavior and an impression of uh female
actresses when they go on talk shows and
they all of a sudden like have
interesting yeah yeah what are we gonna
do about that uh I'm I have a question
for you guys um since you guys are the
president of the internet yeah do you
think do you know more than us I really
do I'm wearing circles around you guys
with these pedophiles and no I'm like I
know the internet read this book by Alec
Baldwin guys we should go to Barnes and
Noble and buy some medieval looking
journals and novels
um I forgot what I was you have a
question for us
yes so James Corden is leaving the Late
Show the show after the
one that starts at like 3 A.M right yeah
like that we just watch on YouTube could
there ever be a version where that the
person that takes over for him whether
they're like I'm gonna have you know
podcast people I'm gonna have sketches
with Tim Dylan and you know Kyle
Dunnigan and Shane Gillis and people
that like the internet want to see and
then celebrities that are actually not
gonna like just lecture you on how to
vote I don't think so the annoying could
anyone do it I don't know it will always
fail because people on the internet
don't want to watch [ __ ] on TV first of
all so your fans don't really translate
and second of all what if it goes live
to YouTube from or CBS YouTube channel
because people like this format and when
you're doing traditional media there's
just way too much
formality to it what if you could make
it and by the way this what if they
offered it to you guys why the [ __ ]
would I want to work for a network this
is way better
right like that's what you realize you
wouldn't even call I would take the call
but you know what I'm saying yeah but
like what you realized once you've been
doing this long enough and whenever
people are on YouTube and successful at
least it used to be where you're like
okay this is a stepping stone we're
gonna make a bigger move eventually and
then you realize that uh
this is way better because you can do
whatever you want you're going to make
way more money you own all your [ __ ] and
um
you find out that that uh even the
numbers I mean it's hard to get pulled
like a million views on T on TV that's
like a really big show isn't it it's
insane yeah yeah it's insane for my
special I just did a bunch of press and
I did like the Today show I did Kelly
and Ryan like all these kind of like
Legacy Media things but the I was like I
gotta do Schultz's podcast yeah that's
again let's be honest you guys that's
where you're gonna pull the it's crazy
it's crazy to think and I think that
coming from as a stand-up comedian like
you really come up going like the
ultimate goal is The Tonight Show like
that's the ultimate role but that has
disappeared it has so hard to let go of
because yeah like that's what everyone
was like working towards and it just it
just dissolved out of you know I'm just
learning especially lately with the
Instagram changes which are very sad
um you have to adapt adapter or not you
know but you have to adapt will you
explain that to me because I feel like
everyone was like Instagram sucks we
want to be on Tick Tock and then
Instagram is like we should probably
change into more like Tick Tock and I
was like don't change well so I wasn't
one of those people I don't like Tick
Tock and I liked Instagram and now
they're taking that away and now
Instagram is becoming like Tick Tock um
they're they're forcing people to make
videos yeah and you have to be you have
to make reels yeah and if you're not
it's your [ __ ] has just like died down
like they don't show it to anyone and
also what bothers me I think the most
first is when they put someone in your
Instagram stories that you don't follow
when they were putting in your feed
people even follow I'm like okay I get
that you have to do that but to put in
my stories right made me think I was
going crazy right you know what I mean
you just see random [ __ ] I was like
who's that like how when did I follow
this person like losing my mind and then
you're like oh I don't like that was
just a minute of my day like it just is
like it's gotten a little bit um yeah
like but at the same time like to me I
was like thinking like it's like telling
Instagram to be less like Tick Tock it's
like a guy who's like no I you're so
much prettier without makeup exactly no
it's like they're doing what's best for
the company and it's like nobody cares
about my opinion I need to adapt or not
use it you know that's the bottom line
yeah they're doing what their customers
the sad thing is the sad thing is
they're right they're right and and this
happens every time a social media makes
big changes yeah I mean Facebook used to
be [ __ ] usable remember when it was
like literally just your friends and
family yeah it's like a casino pop-up
it's like a [ __ ] nightmare look looks
it looks literally like um like better
call Sauls like lawyers right yes it
looks like sketchy yeah like it looks
like a Turkish like Xanax like Hub dude
yes it's so [ __ ] up I think it's gonna
be like like Propecia pills like it's
just it's a very upsetting look totally
I've been off Facebook for years yeah
but like there's still a lot of [ __ ]
that goes down there like all this crazy
video and then people are watching
videos there which kind of blows my mind
they're also big TV shows There Will
Smith was big there yeah yeah Pillow
Talk is massive right Jessica Biel
is that right what like a couple people
uh uh uh what's her name uh Courtney Cox
had a show it like it was a TV for a
while but then they couldn't promote it
like notice Will Smith had a TV show on
Facebook and I remember someone reached
out and was like oh can you post about
this like and I'm like why would you
need me to post about Will Smith but
they the people that had shows on
Facebook couldn't do press about it
really because even within the
conglomerate hypocrisy of Hollywood of
like I'm owned by Disney and I'm gonna
pretend I care about free speech and my
monologue or like whatever like every
network is owned by some cryptic you
know company or Corporation you know NBC
is General Electric at the end of the
day you know and Facebook at the end of
the day is like you know what kind of
like destroyed democracy I'm
exaggerating yeah exactly but zucky owns
Instagram yes like think about like Will
Smith going on like Colbert being like
my new show on Facebook why can't he
promote what you can't like you it's
like the al-Qaeda Network like you can't
right you know you know what else is on
Facebook
um live stream mass shootings yeah well
had I known that so that's good shout
out Mark Zuckerberg I mean sweeps week
you know I'm just waiting is that true
is that oh yeah a lot no I don't know
but a lot of people live stream it's not
happened already a few times dead stream
yeah has happened more than once that
but they take it down yeah they take it
down but like it takes too long yeah oh
yeah there's like thousands of people
watching live yeah imagine I'm just
curious like if it's people like is
there an office full of like hundreds of
people who are just taking stuff down
like they have transitions probably yeah
they have huge farms of people in places
like India doing support like thousands
of people it is a farm yeah yeah the
2019 shooting in New Zealand which was
like just horrific
um Slaughter of 49 people I thought
right it was so bad he went into a
mosque and just started killing people
it was horrible he had a camera on his
head and he was live streaming to
Facebook like a first person shooter you
know and people were at first like is
this real or is this like a weird video
and uh
yeah so that's that's a Facebook Legacy
I just had um uh dick Costello um and my
podcast he used to run Twitter he'd be
great to have like he knows how all this
stuff like really actually works like
who is actually doing the Banning Who's
acting like all this Shadow Banning Is
that real like he is like knows
everything and I said to him I was like
do you think that like we'll look back
in 20 years 30 years and be like
remember when anyone could just get on
social media at any time without a
breathalyzer without like an hourly
daily minimum without sort of their
thumb print without having taken a test
the same way you take a test to drive or
sobriety test to drive you know they're
gonna start putting those sobriety tests
in cars like he's like oh absolutely
like we will look back at social media
the way we look at smoking now which is
like oh you're gonna have to step
outside I hope so because we need help
it's just so out of control like I think
that your kids will grow up and be like
wait a minute people used to be able to
just like look at photos
yeah it's my biggest fear as a parent
right now is like the moment that
Theodore is gonna want a phone and how
do we handle that it's also tricky
because parents go like I mean my whole
special is like about the make an
argument the phones aren't dangerous for
kids are as dangerous as our childhoods
were so if anyone's watched it I'm not
trying to not be like Hokey and say what
already said but with that all my
parents uh parent friends that uh the
kids number one you know where they are
at all times it's a tracking device
ultimately right that's true you used to
just let my mom used to say go out and
play come back before dark and just walk
around and then we come back and every
time she'd be like yeah like that was
all there was and then you also have a
way to punish them that is like
bulletproof it's like
your phone away nothing else really
punishes kids like no more TV like what
right the phone people are like kids are
more behaved than ever because it's like
I'm gonna take your phone away
pretty good points that's a good point
that like you're sexting that you're
looking at porn it's like bro we're
already doing that
as an adult so I'm like how does a kid
handle it but I think that the way that
we had to learn how to handle physical
violence we were in school or not get
shoved in a locker or getting bullied
like one day a girl talks to you the
next day she doesn't we had to learn to
deal with that you know like they might
be having there's always something they
have to learn what they're gonna have to
face yeah like it's true there's always
something we're always trying to fit the
Next Generation into having like when
people like these kids are wearing masks
it's so traumatizing like maybe that's
preparing them for the world they're
gonna live in maybe they they need to
get used to that you know maybe they're
gonna have to wear a mask after life who
the [ __ ] knows what's gonna happen you
know like I think that it's like my
brain is always like this has to be the
best case scenario yeah it just has to
be and I think that like kids like you
know I was just with my niece she's 15.
she is the opposite so I think that
because every Next Generation thinks
their parents are lame you guys are on
your phone
it's like my niece she's 15. she doesn't
smoke weed she doesn't do drugs because
like her parents do she's like weight is
so dorky my parents smoke weed like my
parents are on Instagram my parents are
on the phone all day she like sat there
staring at me with her phone in her
purse I was like wow we took our phones
like a lot of eye contact like you know
what I mean so they do the opposite of
what we do right they think they don't
think it's cool like I was you're making
me feel better randomly Mark Wahlberg's
wife I was on a plane with them
somewhere this is what made me feel like
we're gonna be okay so I was like so
upset that her daughter didn't think she
was cool like her daughter doesn't like
designer stuff because she has designer
stuff so her daughter's like no I'm
shopping at Urban Outfitters and I'm
buying this 20 thing and she's just no
teenage girl doesn't want her Chanel
purse you're just doing the opposite of
what your mom is doing you know yeah so
if we're [ __ ]
like they don't think it's cool they
don't think it's cool to have plastic
straws they don't have plastic water but
they all have their thermos like my
sister comes in she's 24 she has the
freaking thermos
like when I'm oh can we get the water
she's like plastic water bottles I'm
like oh no I mean like Arrowhead glass
refilled spout I mean you know like she
just makes me realize how big of a piece
of trash I am yeah like they don't even
think it's cool or yeah you know
Theodore is already watching like
um there's every time he discovers a new
show that he likes on YouTube so now
it's Junior and Tony and one of the
episodes that he really loves right now
is save the Earth and it's all about
like yeah
we're already watching videos about
saving the Earth love
but isn't it [ __ ] up that like our
kids are gonna be the one that has to
save the Earth
they're gonna be born into like the most
[ __ ]
yeah
dude we're gonna I mean dude the way
it's going what's this right now you
have compassion for kids all of a sudden
this is amazing because now that I'm a
parent I feel like the one this is proof
that God doesn't exist to me is that
children suffer and to me and I know
that sounds corny no but when you're
around a child they're so pure and so
beautiful and so trusting and loving and
like just they're they're pure and by
the way I don't have a kid obviously
yeah but that's how I feel with my
friends kids and with animals that's why
I get so enraged like with animal I have
the same thing with animals
it's also a big like and not to
generalize but a lot of uh you know kids
that have sexual assault in their
childhood like animal abuse makes them
like trigger like I go apoplectic like I
like when you guys saw me it was like oh
just gonna come solve this problem but
when there's like animal abuse or I see
it I I like black out into like a rage
like that I don't remember like that
whole time I went up to save that
giraffe up at that horrible place in
Malibu you said the giraffe well there
was a fire there was a fire it the
Woolsey fire it went all over Malibu yes
and that that disgusting place that um
uh called Malibu Safari up in Malibu
they they pretend there's Sanctuary
they're not they have this draft that
influencers like take selfies with they
they don't take care of it Malibu yeah
well no it's now gone but I wouldn't
evacuate it they had no plan to evacuate
the animals when there was a fire so
they basically got all their fancy cars
out they got their purses out and left
all the animals so I like drove up there
had to get the draft kind of the whole
thing I didn't get him out that day but
I it caused quite a stir and how did you
guys get the dress though we ended up it
was like a long process where
essentially they it was just made so
horrible for them it wasn't funny just
forced them into it yeah it was like
their whole business was like having
influencers come and take pictures with
the giraffe yeah this was a big story I
didn't see anything once it was like
people will stop going once uh it was
funny because I've ever afterwards Logan
Paul facetimed me this was like I don't
know when was this like five thousand uh
and he was like hey how can I help get
the giraffe really make a video I was
like I okay
I was he was trying to rehabilitate it
well no he was just like I want to do
some charity stuff I was like uh I want
to film this bro I want to film this
dead trap
so long ago
is That Yo guys I'll play the sound
bites there was video of the [ __ ] I did
when I was that age I'm sure it would
listen it's still fun
yeah okay so here's okay what's worse
tell me what's worse him was it the
suicide forest yeah yeah what's worse
him doing that which is just a kid being
a kid full of testosterone and who knows
what I would have done back if I had a
camera and knew people would like watch
it yeah and then there's a movie called
the forest
Hollywood makes a movie called The about
the suicide forest is it a documentary
or like a drama drama okay and then some
weirdo producer makes all this money off
of making a show about these people
think I don't know about that one yeah
but that's okay no that's not okay I'm
gonna go put pants on and put my hair up
and drive to a theater and watch suicide
forest movie for two hours I really hate
to say this I think there's someone
hanging right there
[Laughter]
I think there's a giraffe dying right
there oh how I I don't know I'm big on
I'm a big fan I mean he didn't kill him
this person
if you don't harm a kid or an animal he
just played with a dead body a little
bit he didn't play it with it unless we
messed around with the dead bike okay
how many people [ __ ] eat bodies
that's interesting have you seen a norm
MacDonald's new special the one where
he's just sitting at his computer yeah
yeah yeah I love it like he was like my
uh he's so brilliant and he was like
look I don't you know comedians are now
using their platforms to talk about you
know their causes I don't want to do
that I mean look my cause is
cannibalism I
think maybe my favorite
he goes I'm a closeted gay man
I was with Larry King and Larry's like
are you coming out as gay he's like no
don't I'm not gay
how dare you deeply closeted so [ __ ]
funny
um yeah his roasted Bob Saget is so
unbelievable that was like one of the
Great Moments of Comedy because one of
the pros but he like bombed on purpose
he's probably so much funnier than any
of the perfectly scripted jokes
um he was so funny the best but he also
I loved in that um because like again
like the special I'm doing it's just
jokes I'm not trying to like like shame
you and how you voted but yeah he's put
it perfectly he was like you know
everyone now is looking for comedians to
weigh in on politics he's like what like
this is so ridiculous like when Vietnam
was happening was everyone was like I
wonder what Red Skeleton you know so
it's like it is weird to like look to
comedians to be like moral High Ground
now right apparently he said Bill
Clinton killed a guy on The View that's
pretty Epic
what was that about it was it was
hilarious yeah they kept trying to get
him to stop talking about it and he kept
bringing it up and they had like some
gags set up like where he would get a
call from someone and he completely
ruined that he's like yeah we we plant
this ahead of time it's kind of stupid
actually now that I'm out here yeah it
was it was he also had a great
controversy he called into Howard and
said
what was that you remember that
controversy he said something about Down
syndrome well he was going on like uh it
was like an apology tour that he was on
for the Roseanne thing yes and he went
on Howard and then he made it worse
remember Michael Richard after the
n-word video he went on Letterman to
apologize
not funny no he goes I would just like
to apologize to all the colored people
oh he said color and everyone was like
what like you did it again and well
people started laughing at him I think
he said negro oh [ __ ] it was something
where you were like oh my God yeah but
he was also saying like I think
something about the like you'd have to
have Down syndrome to not understand
that it's a joke yeah he goes but no but
the way he did it sorry but it was so
[ __ ] funny and he knew exactly what
he's doing he goes you'd have to have
Down syndrome not to understand that and
then there was silence he says I says
you have to have it down like doubles
down
he had to do another apology tour it was
crazy man that is so right but and you
have to see the um
this is this one clip is this going to
get claimed probably probably I don't
think
I did this show and it was when my book
had just come out yeah the book was
about like my struggle with codependence
and love addiction and you know being in
relationships I didn't want to be in
that's what you know blah blah and um
you can't break up with someone because
you don't want to hurt their feelings
like that's kind of what the book's
about and he opened with I think he was
starting to like lose it a little bit
towards the end there and um wait is
Larry Larry this is when I did that show
isn't he still doing [ __ ] yeah I don't
think he's dead to be honest with you uh
he's basically a cadaver I'll give you
that he's getting Bernie's is one of
them Larry King's Larry King died last
year oh he did oh yeah he's one of those
guys where I was like this [ __ ]
is just gonna keep making YouTube videos
there was this in my brain I was like
yeah that's some [ __ ] I would do because
and to be honest it's about time it was
time I feel like he was 87. he looked my
dog 87 well a dead pan two my two
publicist on the other side of the room
and I just heard
I'd ever been wow but I also thought it
was so funny yeah and then we started
talking to someone's like don't worry
we're gonna cut it out we're gonna cut
like I don't know if he just had started
losing touch or yeah they ended up
cutting out pretty hard open but he
wasn't I don't think he understood what
he was saying it was like a very odd so
you're a [ __ ] yes I remember it like it
was yesterday well he did a similar
thing to Jay Khaled which was one of my
favorite because nobody would put Larry
King on TV he's just too [ __ ] old and
so he's like [ __ ] it I'll go on YouTube
and do my own thing and there's a lot of
great stuff he goes to DJ Khaled so you
like to eat a lot okay remember that
[Laughter]
he said what made you gain all the
weight oh yeah what made you gain all
the weight eating a lot that's what God
Said wild yeah he just got real Reckless
there at the end I don't know if it was
like the what syphilis turns into well
he's dead how can he claim us you know
when like a lot of these guys like got
syphilis in the 80s and yeah they have
these wild tempers and stuff like that's
one of the side effects of long really
syphilis oh yeah if you don't get it you
have a really Mercurial temper you're
really and I was just in the Hamptons
um uh I did a show there and stayed with
Tim Dylan for a couple days and I got a
tick on the crap oh no my crevice yeah
and I had to go on Lyme disease
medication for two weeks and the doctors
were explaining how crazy what Lyme
disease does to your brain and what are
the chances that all of our leaders and
all of our Rich billionaires that
vacation The Hamptons don't all have
Lyme disease and this explains is why
everyone's so nuts at the top dude Lyme
disease scares the [ __ ] out of me Avril
Lavigne had it for four years and
couldn't tour Justin Bieber had it too
and it debilitated him that's where I
used to think it was a fake disease that
dude people said they had to stay
relevant so scary you're out for years
yeah wow yeah yeah did you have mono I
did in your high school did you have it
no I don't think so really there were
kids the kissing disease they call it
out for like a year on that
yeah this was live okay oh it's live
yeah that's why they were freaking out
this is awesome that's amazing I think
we should get the homicide out of the
White House and get like a a fresh start
because we don't want any more murderers
I think we should just the next question
is do we know what he's talking about he
he completely is just making it up oh my
God look at Barbara Walters face
you got it you gotta let it keep going
yeah yeah I want to catch I want to
catch every word here
he murdered a guy
yeah
this is not my week what can I tell you
oh it's not mine either and I'm being
very nice
be a good boy now Norm do you never hear
that no listen we don't need it I don't
want to hear it and this is not the
place to make those accusations and
you're supposed to be funny
I have no idea of course is the person
wrecking with their that's so genius
look how much he knew how they were yeah
yeah here's what I'm watching I'm
watching shows like this comedians were
passed on and passed on and no he's not
ready he's not famous enough so by the
time they do bring you on
you're like I don't care I'm just gonna
lose I'm so mad at you because you you
don't even know you've passed on me but
you've passed on me so many times and
now I just have to go scorched Earth
it's so funny
I thought it was a matter of Records
let me do this okay I'll tell you what
the matter of record you will not be
invited back if you don't shut up
[Applause]
and Sliders
did you ever hear the word oh someone's
phone is ringing so so this was a bit
that the Creator or one of the producers
wanted to set up where he's going to get
a phone call mid-show okay but he
completely messes up the bit it says
that it's a bit live on air they're all
freaking out yeah this is awesome
backstage is like should we still do the
bit yeah well they thought they were
shutting them up by calling them in that
moment
snap him out of it I hope that somebody
calling to tell you to go home no no you
got the phone ringing oh they're being
so much less money yeah exactly they're
ruining it on the phone
hello
oh yeah oh no uh the thing is this
you know Matt Strauss yeah the producer
the producer he told me it would be
funny he said like why don't you carry a
cell phone on and then let it ring and
then pretend like there's a guy on it
no it's a thing pretend
dead man
more Bill Clinton murder uh uh uh
references
nothing better than that which uh I know
you'll appreciate is when Wendy Williams
had Omarosa on
have we seen that that's the girl who
went like was The Apprentice who went
out again you scared the Deep
appreciation for Wendy Williams as I do
I love Wendy Williams No One Missed
Queen is playing huh just saying she
makes uh she may oh yeah that's all of
them
because I guess hosted her show and when
I was oh yeah when I guess I said I
wasn't even allowed to say that really
the standards were so crazy I was like
no but I'm like you know were you trying
to say death to all of them I love that
no death to them all was it that's all
she said to all of them
Britney's Camp yeah so that was
apparently a whole thing
has a point
um but she had Omarosa on you have to
watch it I mean this is when Omarosa was
in on The Apprentice or something but
she was very famous at the time remember
amaroka was like kind of a thing I
didn't know her from the the
trump it is so uncomfortable like Wendy
Williams I mean the queen of just going
like she would just literally be like so
Usher has a new album out I think he's
good but you're just like yeah yeah yeah
dude nobody did it wild nobody did it
like her nobody
and now she's just like disappeared well
she has Graves disease I mean I think
she's been public about and was to help
with some medical stuff but she didn't
you know she's not coming back there was
a bunch of guest hosts and then she came
through shade I think it was like Sherry
Shepherd someone's like oh like should
share a Shepherd like take over for you
and she was like I don't know I didn't
watch her I didn't watch it it was like
something Savage
oh yeah I mean but you think she's
mentally declining I don't know Wendy's
going on she did an interview recently I
don't know if you saw it but she was
like oh she did for TMZ well did you
ever it was a it was not good did you
ever see the the the when she was with
that chef and she was cooking did I not
send you this video they took it off I
think it's on Hulu now because I think
it took all Wendy Williams stuff off of
YouTube yeah why they do that probably
for legal reasons because everything she
says is a crazy Elegance everything she
says is blasphemy liable or definition
it's like the best show ever made she's
like the female Stern I feel like
she's she's to me what Stern is I think
she's more unhinged than Stern she will
just say though have you ever heard the
phone call where she talks to Whitney
Houston when Houston hangs up on her no
like how much crack are you doing are
you on crack right now like it's great
she's fearless oh my God she's way more
she's like the most unhed TV personality
of all time I think she knows what she's
doing she's like I'm here to make good
television black women don't get to be
on TV I'm not gonna no one's tuning out
you know it's like she plays to win is
this the eat-a-lot one yeah yeah okay
how to get this money to take care of my
mother
and not his dad to live good you know I
gotta get those handles I want the nice
car I want the nice watch I want to stay
fresh I want to stay clean you want the
trash there's nothing wrong with that
you should strive for greatness how did
you gain all the weight
I just eating a lot dude he and like you
know the timing of it was just
incredible right like he's trying to do
something he's riffing he's feeling
himself how did you gain all the weight
you gotta [ __ ] love that I mean
incredible time it is it is it is it's
like I want this I want everything oh
you can buy this like not a trainer not
an ad machine
the most played version of the video
YouTube added this and well how are you
like what honestly can you say to how
did you gain all the way there's
literally just one answer I was eating
Larry Larry what color did you think
you're wearing
what color did they tell you what like
whoever was dressing room that's true
they know he's colorblind or like blind
and they're gonna be funny but this guy
he's such an [ __ ] let's just put him
in like ridiculous colors be a
billionaire yeah of course I'm a hustler
you know so I want the nice watch I want
to stay fresh I want to stay clean you
don't say it's nothing wrong with that
it's you should strive for greatness how
did you gain all the weight here
um just eating a lot
eating everything but [ __ ] apparently
right he says he doesn't do that I mean
I guess a lot I don't blame I don't know
if I totally blame anyone but at the
same time I think it's like you have to
say okay you have to do it that's one of
those things that I know the right thing
to do is say you should but I'm not I'm
fine with that personally well the thing
is if you're not willing to do that
because some women don't like going down
on men that's a thing yeah so like you
know I think
it's off the table though if you're not
willing to having it you can't get it
yourself there's no absolutely not
policy no face in general those policies
between two people is fair if you feel
the need to say it in the press or
something that's what I that's what I
don't like it's like you you can have
your own preferences in your in the
bedroom but like to say it don't say it
proudly like that I think a lot of young
boys kind of weird like yeah grow yeah
exactly
just keep it to yourself something's
kind of wrong there anymore that is
qualified to be something you keep to
yourself
[Laughter]
is there anything where you guys are
like I'm not gonna talk about that if
it's not a threat or anything you don't
say whatever no me no I would talk about
it
there's literally nothing I haven't
talked about to my detriment probably
it's I think probably more of a
hindrance than a benefit but that's kind
of always been my policy is that I talk
about every [ __ ] thing everything
that happens in my life
I bring to the show
has there ever been something you share
that you regret I'm sure there's been a
lot
uh not about my personal life though I
don't think so I'm gonna open but like
in my in my
um Journey here
just whenever I came to family it became
too much so family stuff if I could take
something back yeah it would be the
family what's the what is the code of
conduct with kids on Instagram I feel
like it's very split oh people will
completely I mean there's family
channels there's YouTube there's
Instagram pages of you know more
influencing your ins yes so there's
there's influences that completely will
show everything and document everything
but like we've taken the approach of not
sharing
I would definitely be pissed if I like
Turned 18. that's the thing if I was
like why did you do that like right
because yeah sorry I don't no I'm just
saying when when you're a kid and people
show you know remember when your parents
would show baby pictures of you to other
people it's embarrassing it's
embarrassing right yeah I hated that
yeah how much money and the thing is
like I feel like this parents tell
themselves like oh but the kids are so
into it that you know they love it but
it's like but as a kid you know taking
Theodore right now I can get him to I
could get him to do it and he would love
it but I don't know that when he turns
18 it would be like why'd you do that to
me yeah you know I don't know it might
why did you listen to me yeah I'm a kid
you're the adult you should know better
exactly my whole thing with all this
like you know I was just working for
obviously in a corporate environment you
know to do the talk shows for the
special and I heard so much like okay
it's so crazy now because all these
young people in the office and like HR
and you can't say this and you can't say
this and my brain is like why are you
walking eggshells around these like kids
they don't know how businesses work yet
and they're like no but like these 18
year olds they say if you you know like
if you don't say good morning to them
the right way they say you're toxic and
then we have to go to a meeting in HR
and I'm like well why would you just
fire them
oh that's you yeah yeah and then like
well because they you know they'll call
HR we'll fire HR that's kind of why are
they but they're right but how badly do
you need 18 year olds in your office
that you're willing to put up with this
it's not I think it's just younger
generation specific hire a 65 year old
woman named Rita she's so we'll be like
is the worst what do you want me to tell
your wife you're at a lunch meeting
again
she's gonna be cool do you know what I
mean well sometimes you need High
competency uh people and yeah that's
true but I I think there's a there's
there's a uh to your point there's a
certain pushback of going like when I
was working on Roseanne and a couple
people complained to HR about something
that was in a script or something I said
Merry Christmas once and I got in
trouble I was like come to me don't
snitch on me you know what I'm saying
like I come from a PL of a a mind that
it's like if you have a problem be like
hey when can I talk to you for a couple
minutes
you have the power they can't come to
you yeah they're not good you're scary
you know writer's environment where it's
like I mean I always make it very clear
to go like if anyone has because this is
about creative stuff do you know what I
mean we're gonna go to HR I don't know
maybe agree I wouldn't but I think
I think what's happening is people are
just becoming more conscious of certain
issues that happen in the workplace and
people can be uncomfortable confronting
their management
fire you because you're bad with
conversations that's something that
needs you need to be good at what do I
do yeah yeah you can do that you have so
this is the thing about when you were
talking about like kids suffering it
sucks but also some adversity is like
kind of good I don't think they don't
have it like I just mean like you should
be able to say hey that thing just
happened that made me uncomfortable like
you have to develop that skill how are
you going to develop you're not going to
be able to go run to an HR person every
time you feel uncomfortable or like
think about it for a couple days and
then go like hey can I take you to lunch
and talk to you about something like I
don't know those are the kind of people
that I think win in life you and I feel
weird being a part of a process where
it's like oh yeah like we're all just
gonna like snitch on each other instead
of just having direct conversations I
don't know I mean it depends what line
you're in like a different line of work
I don't use sexual assault no I know but
I mean if you take for example our
fashion company where we have HR and
we've got a lot of
like a few dozen employees yeah and so
now it's like I actually appreciate when
people go to HR with stuff so that we
know about it you mean you know when
it's with someone else in the company
but I feel like when you're working in a
personally with people you're in a room
with writers and stuff and everyone's
intimate I think like I understand
that's what it is because sometimes in a
corporate environment there's it's just
a monologue that's true if it's like if
you're at Amazon yeah if someone's being
gross to you in the warehouse yeah you
have to go to HR protect you and and
like these it's there for the people you
know so
yes it's like I I think we haven't been
in a situation that you're describing so
I'm trying to understand that situation
it seems like you felt like you have
you're working together yeah your friend
is snitching but then they're not
telling you to your face that this is a
problem they're going you know why
because also writer's rooms are so
confrontational and you're going I don't
like that that shouldn't work no that's
not fair no like right you and you want
that and you're like wait you had your
chance to do that like you know your job
to be able to push back and to be able
to have these uncomfortable
conversations because to me what it
feels like is avoiding an uncomfortable
conversation that something really
interesting could come out of you know
like okay I can't say you know [ __ ]
now I want to know the right I want to
oh you can't say that of course not what
I'm saying if we bring that up I'm just
using an example I know what do we say
but if you get so mad that I said what
do we say instead of [ __ ] how is
anyone going to know if we can't even
have the uncomfortable conversation I
agree I agree that's why it's become you
can't even say the word in that context
totally I but I will because I otherwise
were acting like we don't understand
context and that is a mass
infantilization of people
I I know what I do why I just like
you're separating the intention of
what's Happening you're dehumanizing me
and acting you know so like like um
here's what it was it was an episode
where Dan I don't know if you watch
Roseanne at all but his character is a
construction worker and we believe that
by the time he is now you know in his
late 60s he is an independent contractor
so he would be losing jobs to
undocumented workers like that just
would be the reality of his life as a
blue-collar you know guy and so
undocumented workers is the term that is
the most respectful I believe yeah today
but we don't believe Dan would have
known that word he would have said
illegal illegal yeah and it's not even a
negative that's the only word he knows
that's what we used to say back when
when I was a bit younger not even that
long ago not that long ago yeah you know
humans can't be illegal so we now know
that term is you know wrong but that's
what he would know and he was in the
kitchen with his wife and he's like you
know this is what happened and they took
her it wasn't even like these you know
now I don't say the word um but uh and
then we fought really hard in the room
about like yeah this word's
uncomfortable makes me uncomfortable but
how else how would Dan found that out he
doesn't listen to podcasts he doesn't
read salon.com he's not on Twitter like
he wouldn't know yeah in that case I
agree I think
it is it is frustrating to be honest
that like I feel like people just ignore
the context you know that is kind of
unfair and and it does it does like
yeah it's just not fair it's also the
story within the show Darlene was like
dad you can't say that and that was a
conversation show so then to have
someone go to someone and go they're
saying a word that makes me
uncomfortable it's like
if you don't know that we all had this
conversation going this is not a word we
would use this is uncomfortable right
then you can't work here you don't
understand what is happening you're just
trying to get us online and I think in
general people are just not
I think maybe I don't know how to I feel
like sometimes people just aren't
charitable enough
to giving people the benefit of the
doubt and I can understand why maybe
that they've like exhausted all charity
and they're just over it but like I feel
like there's a lot more space for a kind
of amicable
discussion I don't think what should
happen at least in the business I'm in
like
raise everyone's salary and see if
they're still as grumpy about words
do you know what I'm saying yeah so it's
like when there's something to kind of
go to because you can't like ask for a
promotion you can't negotiate for better
benefits when you don't have any
leverage and when you're making someone
work 14 15 hours on minimum wage all of
a sudden someone's saying undocumented
or immigrant or sorry [ __ ] that guy yeah
exactly it's easier to be you know but
like how about let's all try like paying
them more compensating the person at the
top shouldn't make 20 million and that
person's assistant well it's 20 000.
it's crazy it's like just shave a
million off and then everyone else is
making a shitload of money I say pay
everyone more money get everyone you
know paid maternity leave full health
insurance see if they're still
complaining about words yeah they
probably wouldn't they probably wouldn't
but so in your line of work I totally
get it but if you look at like a
monolith like Microsoft or Amazon the
thing is you have like managers managers
managers there's like a whole hierarchy
yeah and these people are sometimes
power hungry [ __ ] lunatics who just
want to control you you complain to them
they're gonna try to make your life hell
uh there's really [ __ ] up people in
these in these ranks of these huge
corporations so I think it's it's good
in that case but I understand you I just
like it's my frustrations more the
people that complain about it the people
I can't believe I'm like pay your
employees more like that's true don't
hire more HR people that are taking
money out of the pot like pay them more
you know well here's the secret that
everyone should know that works in an
office HR is not your friend and I love
our HR your friend oh no no but the HR
is a are all corporate shows and I love
that because as a business owner no HR
they're all [ __ ] out to get you but
aren't they more no make sure your
insurance take a hit like who side are
they actually on they're on the
businesses side that's their obligation
their their job is to make sure that the
business owner the person employing them
is not breaking the law not having
liabilities legally and uh just remember
because some people it's not true it is
true also like if you need to get
something done as an employee you you
want to figure out your benefits you
want to figure out how can you take a
vacation when you don't have enough days
yes all kinds of stuff like that they're
there for the people yeah yeah they're
there what are you saying that no
they're there for the people you're
right but ultimately they're there to
protect the company that's their primary
you're the company so well protecting
the company is ensuring everybody's
gonna have a job so that's fine I'm just
saying yeah it's awesome they really are
and there's a reason Michael Scott hated
Toby I'm just telling you but I think
you're right about the point of like
yeah I'm looking at I'm going like wait
a second if I was working for you know
whatever if I was 21 and I was working
for me I'd probably be like oh that
[ __ ] looks you know what I don't know
how to uh you're not confiding in HR if
you are they're telling the business
owner but it's all I I to me I don't
know I just I think I get disappointed
in myself or mad at myself or angry in
general when someone can't just when I
hear someone's talking [ __ ] about me I
don't even care I'm like just like I
think you have to understand though that
that that's not about not giving you
respect it's that there's a power
Dynamic and you are not equal yeah
because you have fame or you know they
saw you they watch you on TV as a kid
yeah there's so like with you
specifically there's a lot more to you
as a person to them yeah you're not like
just somebody else at the work but then
I guess it's like maybe it's just my
line of work where I'm like I need you
to learn I my job is not only to you
know employ you into I want to make sure
that when you go to your next job you
hit it out of the park because if you
leave here with less skills than you
came with I failed as a mentor too like
I always see myself as like your next
job and I'm like always trying to like
help people develop their next script or
their thing I'm like if you can't
develop the skill of being able to go
hey don't talk to me like that you're
gonna keep I get protective I'm like you
have to learn that skill of being able
to have uncomfortable conversations with
people I feel like we just don't have
that skill anymore that's what makes me
well you guys there's there's yeah
there's
there's some people that
I feel like there was always people that
you know
yeah it's interesting but maybe they're
on to something yeah like why should it
be uncomfortable sometimes right that's
true and why should you have
uncomfortable conversations if you can
avoid it I don't know so I think maybe
this are all good changes that it
depends on what it is you should never
have to have the conversation don't
touch me there or don't you know put
weird stuff in my drink but to be able
to go like I disagree with this and
here's why I'm like okay great what like
what's your how am I gonna
change it or improve any work writing
wise if you don't can't explain your
argument to me there's a huge
generational Gap in terms of like the
kids who are coming up now and what
their expectation and Norms are yeah and
then there's people like
my age and probably your age where we do
things completely different and it's
it's like there's a huge
is for me I've learned a lot from doing
this show because I have a more
connection to to younger people and what
their Norms are yeah but sometimes if
you're uh business yet either some have
but yeah uh uh uh you're there's such a
difference uh Chasm between us and then
so when they hear you say like illegal
there they live in a world where they're
like [ __ ] that everybody knows that and
you only use that word as an as a racist
insult and and to me and you it's like
you don't even probably think about it
twice like when I grew up the word you
said
the t word
but we're trans people yeah that's how
we refer to them yeah that's literally
when I I'll do this on live on camera I
don't care when I was a kid we used to
literally we'd be like yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I know we like my
teachers did it my coaches did it that's
what coaches would be like are you
[ __ ] that's what I mean and so like
for somehow like there's such a big
difference that we haven't really
explained ourselves to each other yet
yeah and so there's like a huge
misunderstandings that happens sometimes
and I think over Corrections are usually
good yeah I mean like there's a lot of
casualties but then you fall in the
right place you know
but it's it's if you're gonna try to
cancel an entire so it's like the Fred
Savage thing I don't know exactly what
happened but it's like what if if you
well I don't I don't know what happened
I think it was like toxic work
environment I've worked with him before
he's very direct he's very clear I
appreciate that in people like I want
someone that I don't want someone that's
like good job and I'm like what I I want
something that's like that didn't work
the last take was better this is not
funny you want to try like I really
appreciate directness I think that's I
don't like being paranoid and confused
because I think someone's kissing my ass
or like worrying about my feelings that
to me is disrespectful so I I I've
worked with him before I can see his the
way that he works with a bunch of people
that think
everyone should be besties at work or
something or don't know well what was
the accusation again because they did an
internal review and found like they
usually it's they found that it was
really bad in the review because I don't
think they would want to fire him unless
yeah that was just my experience you
know so I don't know but then you go
like okay is everyone now gonna lose
their jaw you know I guess they you just
have to have some kind of plan for the
job to keep going so everyone doesn't
just lose their job I don't know I guess
the show kept going without him I don't
know because there's 200 people involved
in that wow you know what show is he
producing The Wonder Years oh the rebels
The Wonder Years that's his show oh
that's kind of crazy to think crazy
I mean it is weird to think hey but
while we've tried to find out what Fred
Savage did there's one person in
Hollywood that always keeps it real
who isn't afraid to
bring it to the people uh-oh his name is
Howie Mandel
yeah don't show this to the people only
okay I won't show he posted this on Tick
Tock like two weeks ago and I haven't
forgotten it oh no is he wearing an
Ellen shirt yeah
when my friend Neil bent over this
happened does somebody know is this
covid related and if it is what do we do
about it
ow not
his whole thing that he's afraid of
germs yeah but that's fine
dude there is fentanyl in the water
this is the best how are we not allowed
to joke about like that guy should die
and that's fine okay take it off please
dude I was I I had this queued up I've
been staring take it off 15 minutes yeah
by the way if my vagina don't look at it
like that I'd be way more grossed out if
I did nothing look at that every morning
oh yeah you have a prolapsed vagina
[Music]
right like I don't know dude I think
that a certain amount of money makes
your brain just break well and Howie's
whole thing is like he's so PC he's so
safe and then all of a sudden he comes
out with this and it's just like my
favorite thing to happen everyone like
America's Got Talent and like the master
dancers like God damn it he was it was
on Tick Tock for like 12 hours it had
three million views and now all the
comments and all his tick tocks are like
I'm never gonna forget what you did
Howie and and they took it down you
still didn't take it off the screen They
removed it thank you so they took it
down hold on so oh God where did he get
the video thank you where'd he get the
picture yeah that's a good question I
tried to get him me and how that is now
that I really really like put together
what's what it is prolapse anus and me
how are kind of dogs I texted him I was
like please go into the show to explain
this and he said I'm laying low on the
prolapse for now what do we do about it
but but this is my favorite and the
thing is as crazy is Howie probably has
like a wide range of people who follow
him on Tick Tock considered like safe
for all ages and he drops this bomb of
the book that's on Tick Tock let's go
the thing I mean here's what I will say
I do enjoy like look at my like eye
makeup as I look like I'm gonna take it
off right cool now it it's it's funny to
me just because I okay I'm generalizing
about as a comedian I know that's been
him this whole time do you know what I
mean I love when a comedian just slips
in like that side of them they're that
by accident yeah yeah you know what I
mean yeah like they host the prices
right and they host Jeopardy and they
post Match Game and like they're trying
to keep it together you know
and then at the end of the day the
publicist leaves them alone for five
seconds
comedian to the Bone dude I really like
Howie a lot because me too he no he La
he when code first started there were
all these like comedy fundraisers like
online like raising money for waitresses
of The Comedy Store the waitress is here
comedians look for health insurance and
they're all like you really were the
causes and they were like these four
hour telethons that we were all hosting
and what I I finally was like I'm so
sick of doing there's I can't do that I
mean we were all doing like three or
four day and it was like it was I
remember Saget rest in peace it was sag
it did the first hour Howie Mandel did
the second hour uh Steve Harvey did the
third hour and I'm made fun of Howie
because I was like it's really fun to
watch
um all of them really rich celebrities
find the poorest looking room in their
house
charity fundraiser thing from you see
them like in their basement yeah here we
are raising and but like all those guys
are so [ __ ] Rich that you named yeah
she probably was leaning against a
Rolls-Royce in his garage
Four Seasons like you know the the like
the golf shirts you can get people for
money like at the Four Seasons like
store yeah yeah and I said I was like
can all of you guys just donate half a
million dollars yeah asking poor people
for five dollars let's just donate five
dollars like you know what I mean and so
uh it he was like funny about it I think
I pissed some people off but he was like
really cool yeah
Howie I'll say is a [ __ ]
tremendous sport isn't it interesting
though like I don't know if I had that
kind of germaphobic thing I don't think
I'd want anyone to know about it it's
become so like
I think he I think he's he thinks of it
as activism I think he likes to spread
awareness it's good on him you know yeah
by the way Fred Savage was fired from
The Wonder Years over multiple
misconduct claims in 2018 he's had
multiple
he's had multiple I'm sorry I wrote this
little consumer
a customer of the customer filed a
lawsuit against Savage claiming that he
berated her struck her arm and behaved
aggressively towards female employees
who work yeah this is leading back to
1993. the question is three male
employees the same way they just didn't
report it or is it only or like does it
feel like it was targeted towards
females it does I mean I I don't think
we have the context because I remember
yeah there was a Chappelle joke back in
the day that he did I don't know where
he did it but it was like um uh about
the there was a male rapist loose in San
Francisco and he was like eight men came
forward which means they're worth
thousands yes exactly you know so it's
like do we know right like you know
can a guy go to HR and be like Fred
Savage hurt my feelings like that's a
tough they would be a lot less likely to
do that yeah yeah that's a tough one
well listen
um before you for a long last time I
have to ask the the your your skin has
been a major topic here today oh what is
it within the audience they're like why
oh my God are they oh God
no it's not mean but everybody's saying
like you have the best skin thank you so
I wonder what can you share drop your
skin care routine or your skin care
that's what they're asking yeah do you
have like so I am I talk a lot about
this um I have uh come forward
um about I do use face oil constantly
I'm coming I'm gonna make one yeah I
think I'm gonna make a lot of people say
don't put oil on your face so that's
what I thought so I had really cystic
acne when I was a teenager I went on
Accutane twice wait I know crazy I don't
even know if that's still I think your
liver just shiver shrivels up I'm in
Balance maybe that's what it is yeah
yeah so I don't know because I remember
back in the day when I took Adderall
they made you take a blood test every
every month to prove you weren't
pregnant they made people on birth
control I was like 14 they forced me to
go on birth control because it wouldn't
get pregnant while you're on Adderall it
like performs the baby wow wild yeah
um so I struggle with bad skin my whole
life I had to do cortisone shots like
the whole oh my God because what our
instinct is is oh like I need to dry out
zits right right but that's actually the
worst thing you could do because when
you dry out your skin your oil glands
start producing more so if you actually
put oil on your skin your oil and stop
stop producing as much oil but then
aren't you just filling your pores with
oil I mean your your pores will either
get used to it or they'll start
shrinking like I do stuff to kind of
like shrink them a little bit but I do a
Derma roller I'm I'm making my own oil
it's uh it's called take your own oil
well it's called snake oil I was doing
it with the merge company but then it
was like but you're gonna sell a product
called that's awesome it's just like you
know nobody can use those yeah it's
selling a [ __ ] so yeah exactly like
it's all the ingredients are there when
it's what I've actually been using for
10 years it's a mixture of it's
grapeseed oil wait act wait when you
said that it caused birth defects did
you mean Accutane or Adderall Accutane
did I say Adderall yeah you do oh
Accutane yeah
I took I took Adderall to write my book
and it is a miracle it's a miracle but I
I only took a very low dose that was
what's called time lapsed and it I don't
like it a lot it made my brain buzz and
made me thirsty I tried Adderall once
because I just heard everyone was loving
it and I just I couldn't sleep for like
three days and I was like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
yeah I did have someone prescribe me
Adderall to sleep
because he was like you're having
trouble focusing like you as I'm falling
asleep I'm like oh God I should have
done this I should have done this yeah I
get so distracted yeah yep so he's like
this would actually help you focus on
sleep so a lot of people that have is
bad add as I do it helps them to go to
sleep and I went on right
intent 20 million 20 million grams of
Prozac now 20 million 20 million
milligram you must be really [ __ ] up
no 20 milligrams is not a lot 20 million
yeah no that's bad
um but it helps with like the loops of
like I shouldn't say that you're such an
idiot why did you say that I've been on
electric Pro and Wellbutrin and it's
like bro it's so good yeah I love it I
went on lexical so much in the day and
going made me fat as [ __ ] though really
yeah going off of it uh was hard I got
little zaps I didn't rip I didn't temper
it yes and fingers apps I've had those
before it's really bizarre and freaky if
you don't know what it is it's spooky
because you're like even when you do
know what it is you're like what's
happening it felt like an electric pulse
in your body yeah it's so wild I don't
know I think you used to get those I
used to get those and I was and but I
wasn't on anti depressants or anything
I mean we used to take like MD
and stuff I don't know yeah MDMA really
not like freaking not frequently wow I
was just trying to think like why was I
having brain zaps because it has to do
with serotonin I think
um but and we used to take some kind of
like painkillers that can affect
serotonin sometimes to come down I hear
that MDMA is pretty rough awful so I was
actually went to a doctor because I I
thought I was dying I don't know what
the [ __ ] it was like every once when I
was like having these crazy bite his
buddies out
uh but um
I have had it so much randomly that I'm
like kind of used to it doesn't bother
me but at first it was it's a very
spooky feeling yeah it's a very spooky
feeling but um so yeah so I do um I also
there's this book by Dr Perricone
um called the wrinkle cure about like
things to eat that um are good for your
skin um omegas salmon
um blueberries cantaloupe and then the
three ingredients that are best
topically for the skin alpha lipoic acid
dmae and s3c
um there is a I can't believe I'm giving
this out I cannot believe you're giving
this outfit for free but here's the
thing I have I've bought so many of them
I like have a deal with the company that
I always am going to be able to get it
it's called Source natural skin Eternal
serum right there only like thirty
dollars the Perricone version is way too
expensive it's I don't even think it's
as effective and I Derma roll and then
what's your Derma what does the roll do
it's your hat yeah in a face tool it's
like a little tiny spikes yeah because
most of the product that we put on our
skin doesn't even absorb because we have
dead skin on the top so either before
you're gonna
you either want to exfoliate or do the
Derma roller which is make tiny little
like tiny tiny tiny little holes in your
skin so that the uh product can actually
penetrate and then before I go to bed
it's a whole thing I sleep with noise
canceling headphones the Bose ones so
that I don't because a lot of us we put
all this incredible product on our skin
and go on our pillow and then you just
wipe it off on your pillow and your
pillow is Ageless like that that's it oh
my God but but like work up to it don't
just put all the stuff on your face
right away like you have to sort of
build up to it oh you know what people
use this for on their beards to uh
thicken their hair oh I didn't know that
actually some people use it on their
nipples I've heard there's also a great
product hair nipples the biology for
sure lotion p50 is um I use
um chuda is the Skin Care thing that I
use I also do ulthera I do a laser
called ulthera it is the most painful
thing
um and it is not cheap but you do it
once a year and it traumatizes the like
subdermal layer so badly that it's
almost like a scarf verification and
then so it builds more collagen and then
tightens almost like like a burn you
know when you see a burn oh [ __ ] it's
tighter under your skin
you've worked very hard for that
um what's your routine how much time do
you spend on the female comedians how
have they gone face wise I know it's not
how's it gone historically you're you're
I need to get ahead of it
prevention like just got to get ahead of
it because I know I'm like this listen
I'm gonna watch this back and take notes
amazing
this is a before and after I'm not much
this is for the dirt the Derma roller
really I don't know what the [ __ ]
they're trying to show me well on the
left you can see more wrinkles and
puffiness around the eyes but that's
this because before it was just beards
and stuff what would have happened if I
had gone is that the guy from the
costume store
say what oh no was that a bit offensive
no I don't think so
his name's Gabe by the way I know but
it's funnier than that guy
no because you're being disrespectful
not being disrespectful I can't talk
comedy is disrespectful like when it
comes to Gabe yes
[Laughter]
it's the one time
no I get that
yeah no I love him but to me it's like
you know I don't know in comedy it is so
tricky because we the way we talk to
each other is like that and when people
look at and they're like are you guys in
a fight or like no this is how we talk
like everyone it's funny like all the
there is so much legitimate comedy beef
I think going on right now but really
people yeah I'll do Santino's podcast or
Bobby's podcast or whatever and I was
like why are you gonna fight it's like
no that's just how we talk to each other
I know it's not healthy by the way I Saw
You Did Bobby's uh podcast I [ __ ]
hate that guy obviously he's such an
[ __ ] you guys really I don't know
what I walked into I literally shot in
Canada for like 30 days I didn't have my
phone I could come back to America I
like I had someone do my Instagram for
me I come back and I'm just like what
happened
I'm not oh are you talking about the
Brendan shop stuff well I don't I'm not
I'm I am whatever it was it was wild but
yeah there was a crazy drama but no the
bodies the Bobby's dude he's a piece of
[ __ ] no he's not yeah he sucks we're
supposed to get dinner last week we made
a reservation for four people we had to
put a hundred dollar down payment we
made plans ahead of time why would you
hold on hold the phone he goes to me
he's like yo I'm trying to make you
because you know he's single now he's
like I want I'm trying to go out now you
know I need to make more effort to go
out with people we had been planning
this so he said let's count like a
person you should hold the money down on
hold on dude
dude we had like a whole thing planned
it was gonna be a beautiful evening he's
never had a whole thing planned I did
everything I said no here it is we did
it we did it have you ever get it today
have you ever given a cat a bath stop
defending him well why I like to me it's
I I've spent my whole life am I just not
to do I just never make plans with him
he told me I want to hang out I want to
be friends with you that
he didn't he wasn't lying and because
and so I put the money down
four hundred dollars restaurant hold on
I don't know
it's like a Michelin we've never been
there why are you mad at the restaurant
for this shitty policy well actually
yeah it has a good explanation
go ahead Lena it's called manske
cool wait she has a good explanation and
so they um based on their reservations
the chef will purchase I guess it's like
live food
um that they that they serve so they
purchase like the exact amount based on
the reservations that they have well
they're dorks they're classes
Bobby's the one that recommended it text
him at seven o'clock or want to meet at
Chick-fil-A in 10 minutes that's what
you hang out with well we were supposed
to it started with us going to get
Arby's take notes the fact that he even
attempted to make a plan listen you know
what this is like let me tell let me
just spin because he's an [ __ ] and I
just want everyone to know I know but
you but why would you put 400 down I
trusted it no you're right you're
setting everyone up to fail even if you
had shown up you'd be like well he was
on his phone the whole time and I spent
400 an hour I was like if you have put
that much money down anyone that shows
up is gonna in my book fail listen it
was you gonna finish what's on your
plate you're gonna finish that finish
that you're not gonna finish that like
it could have shown up
at least we would have got what we paid
for so I said anyway we make this plan
two weeks in advance four people we put
the money down the night before because
I know it's Bobby so he says I just want
to confirm that we're going to didn't
get dinner tomorrow we had a babysitter
and everything and he's like oh [ __ ]
sorry I have a show tonight I forgot I
was like [ __ ] [ __ ] I was like
you're dead to me and he goes now we're
even
why did he why was he mad at me again
silly with my money it was the uh the
cancer diagnosis oh yeah I told him he
had cancer and he went to the
dermatologist
[Music]
you need to get that mole checked out
and they were right that's exactly what
happened I thought I was saving his life
and he got so pissed at me I don't think
he wants to live like why didn't you
just let me tell you yeah well he went
actually and got it removed and it was
benign and now he's mad at me back yeah
small yeah yeah he wants them all back
but anyway yeah Bobby just do some [ __ ]
he's not a piece of [ __ ] he's I think it
is trying to ring I think to me I know
all these people so well and I know
exactly
there it's like a it's like you know
when you have an animal or Rescue Animal
you just honor their limitations and
improvement over time that they have and
you don't try to change he is kind of
like a rescue animal he is he's like
he's a rescue animal where you're like
okay the more pressure I put on this
person the more they're gonna feel like
recoil the key to Bobby is if you try to
I know exactly what happened you're like
let's make with Bobby it was his idea I
know but you can't respond it for like
just saying I know okay Bobby he's like
want to hang out ignore his restaurant
his idea then be like yeah sure when's
good for you and then he won't respond
for like two weeks his restaurant his
idea my money you have to do like just
come over when you want like the Bobby
you can't chase yeah or or he feels
suffocated if you try to put a structure
around him dinner reservations I mean
I'm getting anxious thinking about this
yeah I would be like I would have
panicked yeah I would have been like we
can't this is too much pressure I'm
cracking under pressure oh there's
something else I want to talk about
before we go the lottery who's playing
the lottery 1.3 billion dollars Gap box
wow that's [ __ ] crazy that you can
win so somebody can win and become a
billionaire by the way you want to know
why let me give you a question
psychologically yes yeah that would be
great they'll be fine let me tell you
how crazy it is they'll be fine the
suicide forest in no time
theoretically either looking for bodies
or one
both both ends of the spectrum suicide
for us wait say it one more time looking
to be one looking for bodies you can buy
the forest imagine if your big purchase
as a billionaire is acquiring the
suicide for us the dream come true
here this is theoretically you could buy
there's like ah there's uh
999.99 Bill a million different numbers
you can choose it's like one digit short
of a billion so you could theoretically
buy every number and guaranteed win the
jackpot for less than what the prize is
right now uh but you have because two
dollars not one
I am fascinated by well roughly one in
300 million so you can buy you could buy
a 300 million tickets
and well that must be guaranteed to win
I'm sorry you'd be guaranteed to win
right I'm surprised that no one's like
gone hey let's all get together and buy
less tickets
and split it amongst each other so less
people are buying tickets so can you
drive the odds up that way
can we I love being man's land um it's
the only way I can come um if you and I
said hey we let's say we have a ton of
money let's go have these I'll buy a
hundred million tickets you'll buy 100
million tickets and whoever wins will
split it the chances that's 100 chance
we're both gonna get money right
yeah well so the problem is people are
saying that it is a thing in the chat
well I will do it like pool it yeah they
pull it there's big lottery pools less
people play the odds go up and then we
make less money but the chance of us
winning less money is higher chances are
probably because so many people are
buying tickets now that there'll be
multiple winners you know like the last
time there was a jackpot this big it was
like 20 people or something
I can't no you can um you can get the
same number
and they have to split it they split it
yeah exactly
so uh so anyway I'm going over to uh my
local uh uh grocery store I'm going to
be buying a 100 million
I'll be busy tonight Zach how many
tickets did you buy
uh since uh
since the last drawing
I've spent about 120 bucks that's not
that bad yeah you gotta go for it man
Now's the Time the pot odds are good
yeah I know I'm looking forward how do
you pick do you just do random numbers
yeah I do the random Quick Picks is that
who else has bought a ticket I got 20
bucks oh everybody's in huh yeah one of
us is going to win you know no I I am
actually going to win
I bought one ticket and it is in fact
the winning ticket well if one ticket is
virtually the same odds as a hundred
tickets oh make sure to read the first
you guys when I win Cam's actually a
good point Cam said he's gonna give us
all 10 million yeah there's something
kind of like romantic about the human
Spirit yeah I know everyone thinks
they're gonna win for sure I'm gonna win
this time heartbreaking my mom used to
when there when the jackpot will get
this big my mom would buy tickets and
she spend the whole day talking
theoretically what she's gonna do with
the money what the plan is we're gonna
move here the kids are gonna get this
all [ __ ] day like we already had the
money if that is that is couldn't do
that anymore that is something that
would be frowned and fun you're not
allowed to lie to your kids anymore no
yeah but yeah but what do you think
about this DJ Khaled um again is yeah
he's a big pumpic today why people are
[ __ ] on him for buying a bunch of
Lottery oh that is shitty it's a billion
is he gonna hand it out for homeless
people or something
you see what's going on
but by the way that's not money you dark
yeah that's a ticket
that's not money bro can you imagine if
Kyle won a billion though the absence of
money that's a negative number yeah
right on the on the last drawing the CEO
of uh raisin canes the chicken place he
spent like fifty thousand dollars on
lottery tickets and he said if he did
hit it that he would split it with all
the Raising Cane employees which I
thought was pretty cool that's but hold
on hold on but he didn't he didn't win
let me do it if you know if you won
saying you would do something I don't
know I feel like well he could have
spent the fifty thousand dollars doing
something nice from uh right straight
from the beginning just give the 50
right only if I win this thing well I
also benefit if I get the fabulous
windfall of insane money that's like I
remember like every like open micro that
didn't make it I feel like always had
like a great really memorable joke
whenever this one guy I don't even
remember his name but he had a joke he's
gay he is gay and this was 20 years ago
I don't mean I don't know anymore who
knows and he goes um he goes it was
before uh uh marriage equality and he
goes you know he's like I hate that I'm
not equal you know as a gay man he's
like but it is nice to be able to hook
up with guys and be like I would totally
marry you
that's what this feels like if I won the
lottery I would give you some of it like
thanks yes do you think it's corny for
Khaled but to be playing the lotto yes
yes it was awful it's ridiculous that's
why Mariah Carey for some reason I'd be
fine with it cardi B I'd be fine with it
I don't know why see I can't I feel like
I can't buy lottery tickets it's just
too corny because like even if I win
it's just people are going to want
what's worse what's Corner buying one
and showing no one yeah or buying them
and showing everyone
let's create this this but really I
thought something yeah it just shows how
like it's a little naive and like well
he's kind of trying to get like I think
he's trying to get exactly what we're
doing you know after he's gonna like
that because he's so well DJ Khaled is
fabulously rich and it's like bro you
really trying to get that billion
dollars I love when people brag about
the wrong things it's so funny to me
when he's bragging about he's like look
how bad I am with money yeah yeah for
sure like I'm obsessed with rappers in
general like he's a DJ I guess more but
it's like
um I always wanted to do uh like write I
don't know for something like a insecure
rapper character because every rapper is
number one
like I'm number one it's like someone's
number two we the best someone's like
like free and if I just work harder
eventually I like that yeah it's a very
self-aware rapper
they ain't believing us God did you see
children believe in you man they've been
hating they be taking the hinges off the
doors
asking the wrong question the [ __ ] boy's
been taking the hinges off the doors now
they've been putting the hinges on the
doors he's been taking the hinges off I
think I know what you're
which is it he goes all I do is win and
then he's like they're against me like
which is it they well he won despite oh
my God I mean he's not gonna be able to
do all I do is win after he loses the
lottery it's like breaking his streak
All I Do Is Win unless it's the lottery
okay so so all you guys got tickets
though
yeah but I got the winning one no cam
actually wasted his money because the
ticket that I purchased the single
ticket that's the Singleton win oh we do
would you lose by the way when I win I'm
gonna give you several million are you
that guy you'll hook me up yeah well all
the fans are gonna get a cut right
Whitney I will buy you endless supply of
those uh pads thing that you put on like
a guy being like if we ever get married
I'm gonna treat you like a queen
until then until then
what do you do like it's also if you're
dating a guy who won't commit to you and
then he goes and buys a lottery ticket
like that is such a red flag
like you you don't believe in us but you
believe in that he's got a dream it
really I feel like it what would you do
if you were in love with someone and
they went and bought like 20 lottery
tickets
that happens every day I know but what
if I know but
what if you're in love with them do you
marry them
like what do you do
that could be like to me that's like one
of those things like I I really believe
like the way you do anything is the way
you do everything and like if someone
does one thing that's off like I can't
like if if um so the red flag is buying
the lottery ticket this is what it is
like I've been in relationship with
people where they'll like get chocolate
ice cream and the next time we go
somewhere they'll be like how about
strawberry and I'm like what commit to a
flavor you just decide the day of like
what you're like I know before even go
in there exactly what I'm gonna get like
it's just someone that buys lottery
tickets if they haven't committed to you
yet I feel like I would be that would be
such a big fight
so theoretically I feel like you are
such a comedian in the way you even do
life it's like everything you know it's
like work it out pretty well
it's like awesome it's like
going about getting ice cream flavors
like I can't you know it's it's a it's a
lifestyle it's not it's a lifestyle it's
not like uh on stage I'm neurotic it's
like I'm fighting with people at Baskin
Robbins For the Love of the Game like
you're reminding me of Jerry Seinfeld
right now yes everything
yeah people always like why are you
always on I'm like I wish
this is my actual personality I don't
know what to tell you oh wait you ever
get hooked I get hooked on little things
like that and I can't let it go
Larry David still or Larry King David
don't I don't want to hurt him
like my dude now well I gotta I got a a
bed that's big enough for all the dogs
it's called a Wyoming King
and him so yeah I want one of those and
so it's a very so it's big enough to
where if you're just sleeping in it
alone and you get out of it you can just
like see that one person has slept there
you know it's like from from pressed in
New York yesterday and he had woken up
and just left
he didn't recover the bed just put it
back okay that's a problem and I like
don't I don't even want to go home like
I I not you hate it really nobody it's a
small thing
get up and he just went like this yeah
that's that's there was not even just a
just I think that's I think I think that
I think you might be uh is there a big
thing or a little thing that's a very
nice that's not a thing it's a little
thing that means something big yeah I
think you need help
I think that's what it means I'm so
sorry that the the perfect term right
now is seek treatment
but but yeah yeah I think I think
I think you have a heavily treated when
someone like cheats I'm like fair
I get it did you not think you know what
the thing is my mom is like so sweet you
really like he needs to make the bed
you're saying who did you think was
gonna fix it he just doesn't care about
it and yeah and I'm like that nobody
fixes it there if I come home it's not
broken he doesn't see the distance no
there's no problem we never do the bed
let me blow your mind
soulmates
it's like open and then he goes in and
they close it did you play tetherball a
lot as a kid yeah they're Bob I have
played tetherball that's the game where
it's like yeah play it and it's just it
puts itself away yeah it does there's no
there's no cleanup cleanup so for you
there was no mess if the bed absolutely
not see I come home and I just want to
see it I don't need it to be made I just
want to see that an effort was made I
hate that so you take it as a so you're
in love already I'm still auditioning
this person so my mom we both have like
a very similar mom and gotta clean upset
obsessive about cleaning like I didn't
want to have friends over because she
would complain about like they slammed
the door they didn't I don't know he
grew up with not a it was it like I
don't know what the equivalent would be
like middle class message no broke but
broke that's part of it though we have
to replace the door now that I am a
homeowner right right
but it's also about cleaning like or
like the pillows like you sit on the
couch in the living room and then
they'll leave and the pillows are messed
up it's like yeah we're people this is a
house where people leave how hard is it
in it and like I just don't it's very
hard like why would I want to do that
it's not hard but it is hard the ball in
my house I don't want to [ __ ] worry
about how the pillows are somebody
else's home I will fix the pillow if I
should not everybody does that and I
hate I would hate it when my mom would
like get annoyed about these things so
when I met I met Ethan and he was like
he had like all of his closet basically
everything was on the floor not even
kidding it was in college but and I
never I I never lived outside of my
parents house and I saw that and I was
almost I was kind of terrified but I was
also like this is so liberating too at
the same time it was [ __ ] up and you
should have run when you saw that there
was literally a pile of my bed
you know why because I would wash it I
would take it out of the dryer and I'll
[ __ ] dump it on the floor so it's
kind of damp and then once no no it
dried when we moved for example here
just put all of his stuff in trash bags
yeah that's how they did moving I look I
did I think it's because I grew up
without a lot of everything was always
messy whether you wanted it to be messy
or not so now as an adult I just want
things I think I when you spend money on
some I think I just want it to look nice
you know what I mean yeah but I take it
too personal I like to enjoy it you did
you do it's he's not it's because my
opinion is so bad I know I have to fix
it I think it's not his fault I have
those I feel like I have both sides live
inside of me like I understand both
sides because I want the house to be
beautiful and very much about the design
and the Aesthetics and all that stuff
but at the same time I want to be
comfortable in my own home I don't want
it yes I hated that growing up that's
when my house had to be I had to be a
museum and I hate it with like every
sale in my body I hate it yeah I know I
had that a little bit but it was a lot
it was a lot of like why is there water
on the wood that was a big thing water
on the wood if you spilled water or
brought like water in from outside or
were wet yeah after taking a shower I
had to dry all the walls once you
realize I'm telling you it's a shower
this [ __ ] and you just [ __ ] let it
all go because guess what it's just
[ __ ] wood it's just but as an adult
you go I know what that would now I know
if you would rent it because you could
fix it you sand it out you re-finish it
it's fine totally but isn't it as a as a
I look back just I'm in this like
radical we forgive like our parents did
the best they could with the tools they
had whatever because I'm like oh right
we were renting an apartment I was
destroying the wood that you wouldn't if
you're renting and you're not and you're
poor I guess to look back and go oh [ __ ]
it's not that my Mom hated me or that I
was bad it's just scared but also
they're just obsessed with cleaning like
his mom and every minute she's cleaning
basically when we go over
everybody's eating designed to do and
now we can all agree yeah we're sitting
after lunch like just digesting and just
like chilling and she's already like
cleaning my family was above the
cabinets standing up on the kitchen
Christmas as soon as you unwrap the gift
my mom's standing there with the garage
in the bag yeah
hit the floor
but you have to you've gotta let it
[ __ ] go dude and by the way or or if
you can't let it go you gotta understand
don't expect it of your partner exactly
you can't hold him to your standard you
just have to understand that it's not
maybe it's okay for you maybe it helps
you calm down like I know some people
like to clean I really do there you go I
hate cleaning yeah I hate it mine is
more like organized I like to know where
everything is
um but also what I'll say is it's also
I'm learning in relationships you if
something's really important to you you
can also go to them and go like hey this
is important to me would you be willing
to consider this right and kind of the
way they react
my god of course yeah he just doesn't
value that right my love language is
pick up your [ __ ] right okay so that's
fair who's gonna pick it up so that's
fair but like I think there's different
degrees like if he just leaves his
clothes on the floor and you hate that
and you say do you mind just not doing
that yeah he should he should honor your
way yeah it's like the the campers like
he there he can do that for you
but if it's like
and the same is honestly I would also
maybe negotiate like a grace period like
does it have to be right after like
right right right can can the room be
messy for like the weekend yeah I think
it I'm also it's unfair because I am
walking in with all these needs that he
didn't sign up for his person having
which is that I'm always on the road I'm
always touring I'm always in hotels so
when I come home like I was just in New
York for a week I want it to be like
perfect but that's his Sunday you know
what I mean and so it's like I'm like I
do you have housekeepers and stuff yeah
to do all that [ __ ] but I'm also my
housekeeper I've had her for 16 years
she's like my family like I don't let
her do anything I'm like I got it I got
it like I before she comes like I love
her so much I actually cut this joke out
of my um act or out of this uh hour but
it was like about how um like guys now
there's this thing where like the Dom's
dominant sub lifestyle like the 50
Shades of Gray thing is like very
socially acceptable now I don't know if
it was in the shadows before if it was
more popular now or there's more people
whatever but what is it a guy that was
kind of like a you know like dress up
like this and it didn't last long
um but I remember like I can't really
dress up in a lot of like cosplay when
guys are like you know oh like dress up
like a sexy cleaning lady It's like
because I have a cleaning lady like I do
you want me to just ask Leslie for her
rocks and Aeropostale
like I can't get a sexy cleaning main
costume because what if she finds it
like she knows all
yeah
but also it's just to me I think I was
so taught like clean up your thing like
because otherwise it was always who's
gonna do it like who the thing is you
will be internally
eternally unsatisfied if you just can't
you have to accept that like if he does
something it's not personal and
sometimes because it's important to you
and not to him you're gonna have to do
it because it's important to you and
just don't and try not to be mad at him
it's not personal it's just the way he
is and there's probably stuff you know
that he has about you and you guys just
have to learn like I just gotta let it
go and I'll do it because it's important
to me yep yep and I think that is our
main problem right now is we're both
raised to have no needs and we're both
rewarded for being needless and
self-depriving and not ruffling feathers
or needing anything you know so we have
a very hard time asking each other like
could you do this this way or could you
maybe get the groceries this way like
and then we just resent each other
because the other person didn't read the
other person's mind right right but
we're both afraid to need anything
because it comes off weak or awkward or
like we're worried the other person's
gonna keep score like I think how long
have you guys been dating it's been like
like on and on off like we broke up like
twice but like starting at the beginning
of the pandemic oh so okay it's the same
guy that yeah like yes I've seen on your
Instagram and things like that yeah what
do you guys break up and get back
together what's that about he was doing
these really gnarly like tests like um
uh he's a Critical Care Veterinarian and
he had to do these like boards and for
his specialty it's like it's like a 30
rate of passing intense School intense
school and he had this like study period
and it was like during the pandemic when
I like Tim Dylan over every day and a
bunch of comedy and it was just like it
was but it was literally into the
pandemic like six months when I think
touring comedians were like oh we're
never gonna tour again like which is
over like the idea of 2 000 people
getting in one room and just going for
an hour and a half was like great like
we're a murderer yeah like we caused
this like we're actively murdering
people's parents and grandparents so it
was like it was done we were all just
like making weird ass like into zooms
being legging but like it was a
nightmare like we all sort of like lost
our minds and so there were a lot of
comedians that were sort of you know
also comedians are not known for like
Staying Alive as long as they should and
having their brain you know like you
know it's it's a it's a lot of people
that struggle so Community is very
important so I wanted to keep comedians
hanging out with each other and talking
to each other and stay hopeful and you
know I just we can't lose any more
comedians to this like mental illness
stuff you know so um so and he was
studying for these things and I I think
he just felt like I wasn't like or like
he really need he needed to be home
studying and it was it's just such a we
should have just broken up for the three
months while he took his tests so he
could focus and pass because I was like
if you don't pass this because I'm
distracting you like oh yeah yeah okay
yeah so you guys got through that and
now you're back together I'm really big
on Let's Stay Together but like take a
week
like let me just I just need perspective
I just need to get out of my head and I
just need to miss you I just need to
miss you for a minute okay like I do
require like a lot of alone time and
it's like a weird to say but I think the
best thing you can do as an adult is
just know what you need yeah even if
you're interchange about yourself
eventually like this I know this is
where I am right now I like that he's a
vet though that's yeah that's right
that's a great job and right up your
alley too yeah cool yeah it's pretty
safe job oh I know by the way I have uh
I forgot Olivia I have a birthday
present for you it's Olivia's birthday
yeah Olivia's birthday today
happy birthday Olivia happy birthday
come get your birthday present do you
want my frozen eggs
how many you got 16. oh you did you
really do you want to have kids I do you
do 16 of them I do I don't I I'm also
super into adopting that you know what I
got you for your birthday a child I
adopted you a child and then uh bring
out and then bring up bring out Sam the
thing you can open it uh oh you're
welcome go ahead and open it
weirder than the present I gave you
[Music]
lottery ticket
[Music]
only one two oh oh it's a ticket
that's like worse than of any president
Human Resources get them in here now
so who's starring it I don't know
that's the I love the Pantages by the
way such a nice theater nice I saw
Wicked there maybe
thank you happy birthday
[Applause]
happy birthday and then Sam bring up the
thing
okay yeah sorry yeah it's Olivia's
birthday today happy birthday
happy birthday Olivia
[Music]
um yeah do you want just the cash I
could return it whenever I guess no I I
I I can you can you can you can rebate
you can do a cash rebate on that I'll
give you a check tonight check
Craigslist in a couple hours Moulin
Rouge tickets
um thank you I also wanted to say good
luck guys on the lottery money is gonna
get it for sure it's me I don't need the
luck don't worry about it I'm feeling it
don't worry about it I got you uh you
can go if you need to I don't I do I
love you yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh and then say just say guys go watch
the jokes on Netflix also
whitneycomings.com tour we'll put all
the links in the description you can get
tickets to see her on tour and go watch
jokes on Netflix I hope I didn't mess
her thing not saying that I'm the one no
you didn't know by the way no you didn't
do anything wrong it was me it was me
agreed agree I was totally agree I was
the main culprit here you did not I'm
just apologizing fakely Detroit yeah
okay own that as long as you don't feel
well I love you thank you so much for
having me thank you I really appreciate
it
boring
I really love your fans even if you guys
don't like me I really love you guys you
guys are a delight thank you
bye Whitney
[Music]
oh wait wait oh and don't forget your
boss how many things are going on one
thing at a time here guys
[Music]
oh my god I'm an eight and a half
oh my God shut up
bring it out what did we get
[Music]
yo those are fire
[ __ ]
I think yeah there you go she'll put
those up for the camera she got these
shoes from Lisa Frank herself they're so
bomb yeah
and um my feet grew a lot since the
pregnancy yeah I'm I'm a much bigger
size now so huh well thank you so much
um okay so we have a cake let's cut
let's cut into it uh there's by the way
there's soon strumming in the middle oh
perfect that's exactly what I asked for
thank you so much what kind of cake we
got here
[Music]
oh
all right we're gonna go have a little
uh cake party yeah
but uh happy birthday thank you
thank you guys for watching
uh we will be back on Monday if we're
not banned for two weeks we're not going
to be we're gonna we're gonna cut the
lottery tonight
actually that's correction I'm winning
the lottery tonight
[Music]
just for the record I think I was the
only one that said if I won I still come
into work on Monday that's not true I
said that I said that I said I said I'd
keep working oh I would definitely come
in Monday I'd give you two weeks
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's nice that you're thinking in terms
of that but I'm gonna win anyway so I'll
be back on Monday Cameron this is
slanderous I I wanted to begin with that
you guys better not win it's fun for you
guys I'm hoping against you guys now the
birthday girl has something to say okay
birthday girl teacher from my high
school won the lottery
before she became a PE teacher and she
drove a super nice car and she just like
loved doing PE how much she went I guess
a lot of money like hundreds of millions
and she's just like loaded she stayed in
the same job you teach her yeah what are
you gonna do you used to have to do
something still that's true yeah that's
true what are you gonna do dance go home
and sit uh are you gonna come to work no
no I already told I'm gonna I'm gonna
finally asking him I'm the winner movie
projects
dude no I'll be I love podcast and I'll
be here on Monday and then you're gonna
go make movies yes lies not you Dan cam
your movies are gonna stop your movies
hey [ __ ] you all right you're gonna get
your two weeks anymore I'll remind with
my billion dollars in my pocket dude
you're getting five million instead oh
[ __ ] all right so I would come into work
and I would like set like an article as
my background that said I won and just
occasionally tells like hey look at my
screen
well I'd be happy for you why would that
bug me if I won I would still come into
work guys so just know well well I'm
here the same way I'd still be here for
you what would you love you 100 million
would you just quit and disappear no
because I know that I'll
still want to do creative stuff and then
this is it what are you gonna do you
still gotta do something
you know why rich people are like
miserable or like lottery winners in
general are like miserable right we all
know that yeah it's because you've got
to keep doing what you do just do what
you do you just have a lot of money now
you can't just go away
I'll remember that when I come in on
Monday
what do we do about it yeah if Cam comes
in in like a big old fur coat and gold
chains and a crown we'll know and of
course a uh scepter yeah of course we'll
know faux fur all right guys see you on
Monday
God bless all Super Troopers all foot
soldiers
uh and uh
and watch Whitney's special
[Music]
links in the description
[Music]